wow even great moves
hello everybody
please forgive me for being late today
please
please change those downloads to up
folks it hurts my it hurts me so bad
it hurts me yeah
i have a good reason though it's raining
in l.a
that's yeah that's a great reason
well
first of all hello welcome everybody
it's a street tv it's monday monday
monday
sponsored by
yes yes mint
quip and honey thank you to our sponsors
we love you
um
boy it's actually like pouring here when
i was on the freeway traffic was going
super slow and
people on the other side of the freeway
when they would drive fast they would
like blast the other side with water and
you would hit water
you know going 40
50. it was very explosive so
dealing with a lot over here guys
you know well we're glad you made it
safely
thank you so much
how was your guys's weekend
it's good it's good actually
watch dune
did you watch it last night i tried but
either fell asleep
fair enough
even before i got the chance to put it
on
did you watch curb ethan
again
i didn't get to do anything because it
was another long weekend
with poor theodore being constipated and
just i don't know man it's been so hard
it's been hard at home
not much sleep lots of um sad baby
he took two ma i see i swear to gobble
this kid
yesterday i'm hoping
he finally got it all out he took first
the biggest poop like per you know per
body weight pound for pound the biggest
poop i've ever seen like if that came
out of me it would be painful
okay
i'm talking something like this wide bro
it looked like a crisp like a big
croissant
when it came out of it exactly
chocolate croissant no but it was it
wasn't liquidy it was hard
impressive damn like like a stale
croissant
yeah
and then and then after we're like wow a
few hours later he took another poop the
same size
so i'm hoping that
you know he got it all out
yeah how'd you like doing and uh curb
how'd you guys like it i'm gonna watch
it obviously
i didn't get to see kirby go ahead no go
ahead no you go in there no
i proceed i was insane yeah dune's
really good i didn't read the book and i
still enjoyed it so that's fun yeah
i know how do you like it dan cause i
know you're a fan of the book i i
enjoyed it quite a bit it's it's not a
perfect movie and it certainly um
it it
just ends in like a really arbitrary
place which everybody warned uh viewers
about that it doesn't conclude in a very
satisfactory way because it's um they
split the book into two so there's
theoretically a part two but they're uh
place i mean there are worse places they
could have ended it but it certainly
doesn't feel
it just kind of ends like almost like an
episode of a tv show would mid-season
that's odd
yeah yeah but it's doing good you know i
know that there's like a huge fandom
around this book like people love this
book and um yeah yeah there's been
attempts to make movies before that were
horrible so i'm glad to see for fans of
dune that uh
somebody actually did it
the gun did it
and i'm i don't know i'm not
i'm just a little skeptical with this
guy as the lead because i don't know
he's just like this flavor of the month
actor but did you think he was good
yeah i thought he was good i went in
wanting to hate on him but i was
impressed there you go
so i'm excited to watch it actually when
i get a minute
especially curb how was curb your
enthusiasm zach it was so good i can't
wait it's going to be a great another
great season i can't wait that's that's
what i'm really excited about um
it was there was never a dull moment in
the first episode well i'm very excited
about that
so
listen we got a fun it's halloween week
we got a great
programming this week we got a great
show today
um
i got canceled for so many reasons this
week
um
jordan peterson fans canceled me
um
and i guess it's also just a joke about
how uh
the subreddit has been cancelling every
person
one of the every person that we mention
as like a meme person gets canceled in
the subreddit before we even get a
chance to like enjoy uh
having them on the show
apparently the island boys are canceled
and i'm like
everybody gets to have fun with the
island boys
i and then all of the subreddits like
island boys are canceled ethan can't
talk to them i'm like dude i i i we
discovered the island boy well no
everybody else gets to enjoy them
yeah i um
when like the day after or i think it
was the day of the first time that we
talked about on them on the show i
jokingly to the crew was like anybody
want to take bets on how long until the
island boys are uh canceled and i said a
week
and then it turned out to be like two
days yeah it was like half a day
[Laughter]
i mean who would have guessed that those
guys had a questionable past who could
have guessed
well there's one video of one of the
guys
i guess what he did is he hit his
girlfriend
and then well what's weird is he so he
hit his girlfriend
but the video of it is just him getting
his ass beat by his girlfriend right so
apparently he hit her and then she like
literally beat his ass and he's crying
and he she's pulling his hair and
punching him and he's like
he's just literally crying being like
let go my hair look over my hair not
that hard honestly
i don't know that they ever claimed to
be hard though they're just island but
he took talk about his glizzy
uh true maybe he was talking about a hot
dog after all
they claim to be hard
his friends were questioning him about
that video they were saying you look
like a little [ __ ] and he's like oh you
know you got to play that [ __ ] up yeah i
saw that too i i did the whole island
boy deep dive he's like you got to call
that play that [ __ ] up cause they're
gonna she called the police and you got
to look like play the victim i was like
all right island boy
such a shame too because they got he's
in my dms and we were ready to have him
on but uh
turns out the island he's going to is uh
alcatraz
rikers
[Laughter]
yeah this island might be more of a
castaway situation than a uh good island
vibe
and there were and then another girl
that got canceled was one of these girls
from
the bachelor that everyone was like yo
have to have her on a talk about it and
then they're like no you can't have her
on because she did all this stuff well
and the stuff was weird i i agree you
know it was weird
so can't have her on the show although
one person that has been canceled yet
that i do want to have on the show is um
uh uh jacenia
shout out to the real one she's a
bachelor nation girl from the bachelor
he's a fan of the show who's gonna call
in you haven't
heard what's going on with her oh stop
jacenia's pure is gold how dare you no
just any of slander she's all i have
left
but one of the comments very true was
like dude at this point even ethan's not
even uh
even ethan can't be on his show his own
show
by your guys's standards
but you guys want to watch there's so
many great stuff today
and today
i'm just going to say it
our are off the rails really you don't
think i can say it ian oh i was running
the surprise
it's not a surprise it's hype you're
building hype
how is it come on it's building hype you
got to spoil every surprise it's not a
surprise it's a whole video how am i
ruining it
i guess you're right we're building high
yeah because if you just drop it people
are not going to know necessarily how
epic it is okay and the dremel has
already started i mean we can't
guys if you if if we can get
enough of you to reverse your dislikes
to likes i will i will do the surprise
we got a hundred down
oh really oh yeah went from 6 11 to 5
11. so 100 more 100 less dislikes and
i'll drop the surprise right here right
now all right keep an eye on that ab 200
200 here we go now boy let's do 200 200
a b
no dislikes there needs to be zero
dislikes on this zero dislikes hunt each
other out
report on your neighbors
you guys want to watch um
yeah then the other thing was these
jordan peterson lobster cult were so mad
at me for making fun of their lord and
savior
jordan peterson
they uh
it's a it's a a disgrace
because he was on our show like [ __ ]
years ago
i just don't understand like people on
the right or even i guess people that
like jordan peterson
they say they're the same people that
defend dave chappelle and say trans
people need to take the joke right
trans people need to take the joke he's
joking they're getting too offended but
what i see
and i'm just goofing on jordan it's even
le is not even calling him out in the
way that like chappelle is calling out
trans people you know
um
what i see is that they can't take a
joke
i'm just good on the man
it just meant it's jordan peterson
crying about how
how about poor men
where would we be without men
you guys think it's a joke
[Music]
where would we be
without white straight christian men
people are saying they did it on the
likes
they did it well that's what the chat's
saying oh okay is that accurate i'm not
seeing that yet but we got a hundred
more down our data our data says
otherwise i'm just going to drop the
surprise so we can move on oh so tonight
right after this
we are going to a undisclosed location
because this is a live show i'm not
going to tell you guys where we're going
but we have hired a professional
medium
psychic
to give us a guided tour
of one of the most haunted locations in
the whole city
the whole united states
in the world really in the whole united
states yeah it does sound like there's a
lot of crazy history here we are all
going
hey i am so excited it's gonna be so fun
we're gonna have like ghost packs and
[ __ ] and zach is [ __ ] terrified which
i think is funny
i uh wearing my star david today you
know
god protect me
you need that evil eye dude yeah i don't
think the star of david's gonna help you
no no it's all good you know they'll
know okay but yeah i'm pretty scared
shitless to be here zach was telling me
he's been having nightmares i was like
dude
horrible nightmares
yeah so what are you afraid is gonna
happen i'm just like don't [ __ ] with
like
possession or demons or [ __ ] like that
like i saw the exorcist at a young age
and that really scared the [ __ ] out of
me pretty sure a lot of people did what
are your feelings on ghosts and ghouls
well like
isn't it kind of the same category no
ghosts are not the same as demons yeah
demons are hellish well monsters of uh
of hell how how can you how can you
determine if it's a ghost or a demon
don't they take the same form
no no no no no ghosts are like someone
that's dead demons like straight from
hell yeah yeah can't ghosts turn into
demons like what if someone i think
demons are well
well
demons
i'm not an expert on this field by any
means you're not a demonologist no there
are people that say they are
demonologists that's a real field i'm
i'm just scared
i'm scared well we'll take good care of
you if i get possessed you know just
yeah demons are are
essentially like fallen angels right
like they weren't even like humans well
demons have bodies ghosts are like
ethereal beings that drift between the
worlds demons are like you know
from the pizza physical monsters right
come on dude so you're afraid of demons
still physical monsters coming and
killing us there well and ghosts like i
i just i don't want to see [ __ ] if i
hear something okay you know that that's
me being skeptical do you hear something
that that's [ __ ] yeah but like if
you see some [ __ ] it's like oh [ __ ] this
is real oh does abe have the uh well
here yeah so in the spirit of halloween
here let's dive into this ghosts okay
the old classic when it comes to
supernatural entities ghosts are known
to simply be
the spirits of people who have passed
away
not you know not necessarily evil benign
yeah they're lost casper friendly ghosts
also there's been friendly ghosts i [ __ ]
with casper he's my homie they tend to
only make themselves known by sighting
but are also said to be able to speak
change the temperature of a room and
bring a certain odor what's that smell
see that's [ __ ] dude i'm gonna fart
near you and you're gonna get freaked
out
now demons are defined as an evil spirit
or devil especially when thought to
possess a person or act as a tormentor
of hell so they do possess
that that i'm [ __ ] scared of dude i
don't want to be [ __ ] pissed i i i
don't think there's any indication of
demons perhaps ghosts but
though there will be no demons
how can you promise that
how can you promise that dan maybe i'm
already possessed
watch a demon die what's your demon nah
well anyway
i'm excited it's gonna be fun times baby
so that's what we're doing tonight oh
gussy
people are saying we're gonna get that
gussy tonight that
that good uh ghost [ __ ] yeah you got it
everybody random applause for ethan yeah
some people have sex with ghosts and i
always thought like damn that sounds
like as a kid as a young virgin child i
was like i'll take it i think whatever
one of the ghostbusters had sex with the
ghost got a bj
he did i don't remember in the film did
he finish there is some moment in the
movie
i don't know well his eyes go cross-eyed
i believe so whoa
see gutsy is good and then in the sec
he busts that ghost
the second scary movie there's a ghost
uh
uh sex scene like you don't see the
person but
see what's wrong with that
it's [ __ ] weird dude
i just don't [ __ ] with this [ __ ] i don't
know okay all right well we'll take good
care of you i'm scared all right
we have a professional with us she's
gonna that's gonna call more [ __ ] dude i
just she's there to war she does this
every day this is her profession she's
been she's been on like ellen she's like
the real deal oh no i i she's [ __ ]
legit i'm i'm kind of excited for that
sense but i'm just i don't want to walk
out there [ __ ] possessed that that's
my big [ __ ] thing
i don't want to go home and say you know
some weird exorcist linda blair [ __ ]
who sent this uh well apparently
anonymous source anonymous source sent
this tweet in from tricia i want to have
sex with john lennon's ghost so bad you
don't even know i think it could happen
well fair enough if you're gonna
sleep with the ghost oh
john lennon it could happen
i like her optimism imagine that huh
yeah by the way guys if you want to call
in you know the number it's 808 hot meme
we are screening calls now
um
is this one of them talking about jordan
peterson worth maybe you need some time
stamps
it's a couple of reactions oh we don't
need to go over that i didn't know how
to go into it i just saw it at the top
of that what are we gonna do with that
man
we have so much we have man we have the
funniest video ever posted the internet
to get to
do what do we do without men
they build our roads
they go to work
they
men they bust in ghosts they sex with
men
i just i don't know what to do without
them
[Music]
what would society be
the beautiful strapped man
i don't like this no more all right
enough of them um
okay one more thing h3 shop
limited time you have two weeks or less
now to get these
brand new limited edition
[ __ ] rank kavanaugh drop
the official [ __ ] ryan you got to govern
yourself accordingly you've got the r
kelly do you have your passports you
have your shots girl would you like to
come back with rob to america um
certified lover boy tea
and of course some beautiful fan art
uh tea as well so
you have two weeks
h3h3shop.com or even less now
is there a timer on this
oh
november 16th
yeah okay so you have a minute
got a minute yeah
all right let's get into it
um do dj khaled man
we got him dj khaled used to be a
mainstay of my
channel
yep back when i was doing videos good
old days and you know he it was like you
put khaled in the title and people are
like i gotta see this that's not so much
anymore like cal doesn't pull in the
views like he used to but
he's still a legend man
and this proves it he is a meme
factory you know his bob marley's family
sent him like some limited edition
guitar
to commemorate
their father
and
this dude literally just
disrespected his memory i feel like in
like the most horrific way possible
um what did you think when you saw what
he did to that guitar zach
just take some lessons man like just if
you're gonna strum a [ __ ] chord like
something don't just [ __ ]
pretend
you know all right well let me play the
video
here it is
get it close up get a close-up get a
close-up of the case
the guitar
i'm saying in a special note from the
marley family shout out to marley
melissa can you read this for me can you
read this to the world please okay
this was something that struck me as odd
can he not read
i
i don't know because like i just i it
really stuck out to me how he asked
someone else to read it
in that fashion
i don't think he can read can you find a
video of dj cloud reading
something i'm looking right now because
that i i kind of want to dig dig on this
one i mean
that that that that that
this can you read this to the world
please
okay um dj khaled we're excited to share
this new guitar with you as someone who
has an appreciation for bob marley's
life and music we want you to be one of
the first to play the guildy 20 marlin
based on bob's at home songwriting
guitar from 56 hope road this guitar
inspired songs that help unite the world
and we hope it gives you inspiration as
well
[Music]
they go dave we want you to be one of
the first to play this guitar
[Music]
i mean what uh
you know what blows my mind is this man
has written so many
so many number one songs who uh yeah oh
you think he it's it is kind of insane
being around musicians and music he
hasn't learned to play one chord that
just blows my mind that's true that's
that's actually a good point like
just maybe he knows how to play the the
another one because that's all he says
you know
congratulations you just played guitar
[Laughter]
that's funny
yeah
um that was pretty tragic i have to say
somebody noticed that he's always
wearing a bathing suit that's true
yeah that that was that was horrendous
but like
really just you're gonna
just to throw him a bone for something
i'm not sure
i guess yeah he has some rhythm
[Music]
he probably practiced for this yeah he
did
it's just
what do you think about his cord work
they get a close-up here
look at his hands here on the neck he's
got the thumb going dude
yeah that's i mean that's high level
technique when you include the thumb
dude that's next level dude
i've seen dudes do that you know like a
sick of
you know with like you have to push down
an extra cord up there with your thumb
okay here he's reading that dude's not
reading this is the only evidence we
have
this is all i could find these
screenshots okay he's reading
something
okay interesting so we have some
evidence what's the context of this one
um
just another one
oh oh love's got a link here let's see
yeah we're investigating i don't think
you can read can dj khaled read that's
what we're trying to figure out here
today i'm saying that he didn't finish
his education no excuse me not for
release oh my god he can't read
he can't read wait i missed the play
wait he's wait listen to this
not for sale no excuse me not for
release
this [ __ ] cannot read
there's more clips like that yes keep
them coming
because i actually i feel like we might
be on to something i think we might be
breaking a story interesting oh sorry
not for resale okay
so you didn't get it you know
the reason why i told you not for sale
not for resale or release
because that's what that means basically
all in one
yeah next save
okay there's more evidence maybe he's
dyslexic or something maybe he just has
uh trouble reading
might be totally illiterate okay well
hold on let's get to the bottom of this
i think you did a great job
from your circumstance what's the word
circumstance circumstances
dan's always quick to remind me that i
shouldn't talk about uh yeah
mispronouncing is very different yeah i
i read good xxs
[Music]
yeah yeah then we'll get it next time so
my sound is accurate oh yeah accurate i
remember that it's a real sound and i
made sure that
i'm so good
well you know i make a bunch of sympathy
i'm saying like that's what i do my
anthem
i do exactly what this did
interesting well that's just
mispronounced yeah mispronouncing's
different i mean so usually
we would never criticize anybody for
mispronouncing things
i mean accurate is pretty good
accurate xxx tenacion
tentacion right
yeah
see
look at you
um that's just boomer though i mean come
on
well he's a boomer
or closer closer i don't think that's
why i don't think that's the problem
though
khalid age
is 45 i guess that's gen x but
all right so we got here what do we got
can you even see these on screen
oh yeah you can this dude made
pokemon cards for us
sick
so sick rap trading on instagram
i wish i had close-ups so i can read
the info
but
oh here you go let's see
now you can't read it
dan has a pretty cool attack on his card
dan says
dan disagrees with your opponent's take
and views lowering the morale this turn
they're all pretty good ethan vape
nation flip a coin if heads ethan blows
vape clouds in your opponent's face
blinding them for a turn
ela ceo mindset your opponent is on the
wrong street confusing them this turn
she's a big pimp
ian the salaried employee
aien hacks into your opponent's
mainframe lowering their attack and
raising his salary
that's funny
zach the sound lad mayo smash zax
matches all of your opponents mayo
lowering their attack he's the golden
boy
a b simping a b sims for your opponent
distracting them this turn he saves them
from a burning car crash that's nice
that seems like a helpful thing to do
oh yeah because it never hap because
i don't know i'm stretching excuse me
lovebot
the fika break love has fika with your
opponent causing them to bury the
hatchet and battle for this term that's
badass for life
olivia
vomit escape
your opponent
vomits this one's hard to read your
opponent vomits all over the battlefield
allowing olivia to escape battle this
turn nice and cam
photoshop battle
cam photoshops your opponent's ideas
in record time raising his attacks and
confusing them this turn
yeah these are and these are like nice
ones they're all shiny and [ __ ]
yeah they're foils man
this guy who's this guy uh rap trading
on instagram so sick shout out to his
family i wonder if we can make like a
pack
so dope like actually make a bed yeah
why not i don't know how he
i don't know yeah yeah his stuff is
really cool he sent ian a bunch of uh
kanye ones
oh for real yeah here's his instagram
rap trading oh so he just makes these
are he makes them really good
well like doja cat
yeah that's cool
so
we made it guys we got our own trading
cards now
so cool
cool
um
oh yeah talking about island boys and
and once again it's like
check this out
island boys x grand rising dude
across the fact that you are watching
this video
means you are energetically aligned with
me in this message
such thing as a coincidence live your
life get your back
go up live your life man live it up and
stay blessed and stop playing man island
boys
stop playing
the [ __ ] screen the fact what is he
he's fully embraced what is his content
he's just he's just mement at this point
that was such a weird video he must have
paid him for it
i don't think so i think that was i
you're telling me
i guess that would mean there's no such
thing as a coincidence if he paid them
could be
otherwise
that would undo everything he's fought
for
um
what is this
i want to watch a video let's see um
actually do we have any interesting
calls
some
from the body count video reacted to
wants to take a crack at making ethan
laugh
was in a cold for 20 years
the cult is starting to get exposure
right now and they're getting sued for
talking about it okay and they want to
talk to me about it
boyfriend cheated with a 13 year old
girl
skip skip
stalked
and now her boyfriend resulting in a
stranger wants nintendo back what the
[ __ ] is this who took this one i'm just
i want clarity
so the boyfriend cheated with a
13-year-old girl and this girl wants her
nintendo back
should she fight for it
this person is popular on tick tock for
doing
spot on old justin bieber impressions
here let's take let's do the cold one
okay
let's see here oh 41 okay miles seen
some [ __ ]
miles you've been in a cult
hey ethan how's it going yeah i'm i'm 41
i'm an old guy i'm probably like your
oldest listener you're only five years
older than me so not that old
uh that's a good point yeah i was uh out
it's an alleged cult that i was in about
20 years ago
um but there my sister was in it and a
lot of people that i know uh
you know they're they're talking about
it now i'm like this facebook group
and
because they're talking about it
they're kind of coming after them with
lawyers
they have money
they have money
what's the name of the call
uh i'm afraid to say right now
because i don't know
i haven't talked to a lawyer yet and i'm
actually
uh working on a documentary i've been
working on a document for like a year
about it and
i'm just trying to get like i don't want
to do anything stupid you know like say
something that'll get me in trouble
later
okay so
so how long were you in this cult
that was in it for like a year
just a year
and you so what what's culty about it
well
if you look you go down the list of like
what the fines are cult that they pretty
much seems like they hit those
those markers like fear of the outside
world
they
emphasize like you know having control
over all aspects of your life
um you know using fear
and uh
stuff like that so it's a lot of things
and there's some allegations that are on
that list that would just kind of or on
that facebook group that you would
really you know so what stuff did you
see that made you like worried like oh
[ __ ] i gotta i gotta get out of here
you know what it wasn't until a couple
years later when i was in the military
that i thought back like randomly like
was that a cult it just hit me like
maybe i should look it up um so they
what made me leave though was like i
couldn't take it anymore i felt like i
was
you know being hit from all angles like
god and the devil and all this stuff and
it was just too much and i was really
young then and
i just couldn't take it so i just packed
up my stuff and i left
well i'm glad you're out of there
thank you
uh but yeah i'm wondering like what you
would recommend for um
like if you recommend talking to a
certain type of lawyer because you've
got you know you i really respect the
fact that you've gone head to head like
fearlessly
and
faced people that were bullies and i
commend you for that and i i want to
be you know i want to learn from the
stuff that you've gone through well i
don't know anything about the cult i
don't know kind of what crimes they've
committed
and i don't know how rich they are
so without having that kind of
information
i don't really know what kind of
attorney i don't think it really matters
i think you got to find one that you
like and probably one that's not that
expensive because
if they do want to litigate
it's hard to say because like you want
to talk i don't know where do you what
part of the country do you live in
i'm in chicago okay they're definitely
good lawyers
there yeah do you know i can give you
more info if um i can send you maybe
like a trailer that's
unlisted
for everything i've done so far okay a
couple minutes yeah send it i'll watch
it later i'll get into it later but for
now i would just talk to any lawyer just
tell them get on the phone talk to them
about your situation they probably give
you a consultation until you set you on
the right way there okay
okay all right thank you do you have
money how much money you got you have
enough money to deal with this [ __ ]
um not really but yeah
we'll figure something out
yeah i would i would just tell you that
usually when people drop documentaries
about a cult or something they have
resources behind them because like if
you are working with hbo or netflix or a
huge platform like that then they're
going to help with the liability and
assume the risk like you know like what
you saw with the scientology stuff and
all this but like if you're just acting
on your own
um they will one hun they're gonna i'm
sorry to tell you but
they're gonna win dude if you don't have
the money or the resources because
they'll just [ __ ] you up they'll just
[ __ ] you up i mean the first time we
went up in the lawsuit
we at least had like a fan base and a
voice so we could talk about it and we
were able to get help from people
but like if you're just on your own
anonymously
um
just
even responding to one lawsuit with a
cheap lawyer is gonna set you back you
know
tens of thousands of dollars and and if
you can't respond they're gonna win
the judgment against you
so yeah that's a good point i wouldn't
well we do have a good network of people
and they're you know it's actually in
kansas city and uh it's like a revival
so there's a lot of like shouting and
like craziness
and so they get a lot of attention and
they have money but it's still like
under the radar and they've been under
the radar for a long time if it's what
happened colts generally have
people in the cult that are lawyers so
they're gonna get [ __ ] for free they're
not even gonna pay for it you know what
i mean
like if it's a successful call they have
people there that they don't have to pay
for their professional services
i would try if you're really serious
about the documentary i would seek out
of someone to partner with otherwise you
it's just it might ruin your life i'm
just being honest with you
yeah that's a good point um
you know i've been working with people
that have done documentaries before so
you know they're giving me advice and
i've had good advice
but um
you make a good point like i have to
make sure that i'm covered legally and
if i could share that
with dan or something if they want to
take a look you're going to share the
what the trailer you want to show it
that's going to give away who it is yeah
are you sure you want us to show it if
you're scared yeah
because you're definitely going to give
yourself away
oh yeah i just spent like maybe offline
or something oh yeah so you can use that
to dan yeah
but like and if this is a if this is a
cult like you know a really
if this is a cult cult like you know a
good one a cult worth its uh weight
they're gonna [ __ ] ruin your life you
know they're gonna be they're gonna ruin
your life and they're they're gonna
you're gonna lose the verdict and
they're gonna keep [ __ ] with you too
you're right
i don't even care i just want to help
the people that are in it to get out if
if it needs to [ __ ] up my life that's
fine so i'm just going to do this
regardless i'm going to try to get them
to even you know talk about their
involvement i've asked them to speak on
behalf of them there was a story on fox
4 about it i just gave it away there's a
story on fox 4 so
news
i will never be
and uh
it's also
if you look up fox 4
kansas city there's a story on it and
i'm sure they're going to find out
anyway so i might as well say it's a
world revival church in kansas city
oh
we're doing it let me see what these
guys are up to world
revival
world
kansas city but they won't know who you
are necessarily right
i think they remember me but it's fine i
already asked for an interview so
they they basically know
we're over viral
there's oh here controversy there's not
much out there about it
uh former members accused world revival
church oh yeah here's the
congregation or cult former members
accused of church of abuse
christianity like a christian disneyland
that sounds fun they're super christians
great
oh jesus that was a good start
i'm in that story and then my face is on
it too oh you're [ __ ]
you're already [ __ ]
no i because they they didn't i just
said that you know what i told you i
just felt overwhelmed that i left and
that's all they put in the story oh they
even gave a statement to the news
cast
but wait what are the allegations
what are they on the candidate
what kind of abuse are we talking about
survivor on facebook
i'm sorry
what kind of abuse are we talking about
here
like they would um
they would kind of starve kids if they
behaved bad i mean that's a legend
everything i'm saying is a legend
um also like um
you know they wouldn't
let you kind of have a life you know it
was like five hours a day
six days a week you're in church
um
sounds like that and there's a lot of
weird stuff that happened that
i still wrestle with today um
and i i know you used to talk about like
supernatural stuff on your podcast
and i'm very interested in that and i've
always been focused on it because there
was definitely like a feeling of
supernatural energy
but that usually with a cult there's
some dude at the top like having sex
with young girls is that happening i
feel like that's like one of the that
like is what that's what it all comes
down to is there a cult requires one
dude at the top who's controlling the
whole thing is that going on
yes
no no no no no no no there's a guy at
the top but there's no sexual
accusations against him i want to make
that clear okay
definitely good to cover yourself
yeah yeah
there's nothing
to that regard but there's been some
cover-ups there's another story in the
kansas city star about a member there
who was
says that she was uh assaulted and that
the church knew and they covered it up
oh well that's every church somebody
related to the church
yeah that's every weekend at the church
all across the world unfortunately oh
yeah
yeah but if you go to the kc cult
survivor on facebook um they have kind
of stories of upon stories of things
that have happened so it's really
valuable to me to have your
honest opinion about what this whole
situation seems like because i'm so
close to it so i appreciate it all right
well good luck miles um obviously it
will take me some time to understand the
situation so i can't start to get into
it right now live on the air but uh
give them hell
and uh hopefully
keep your soul from going to hell as
well in the process yes indeed
you're going to heaven bro okay
you heard it here all right miles just
for being a listener
going to heaven ladies and gentlemen
um
there was one other caller that looked
really interesting i think yeah so liam
so you guys remember um
hey liam i'm just updating everyone on
what happened so maybe you can give me
the video to refresh people so liam here
we watched this guy who was looking for
people
to send
videos of their bare feet driving was
actually running as a youtube ad which
was what was so funny about it
and liam here apparently applied
is that right
yeah uh
so uh i am in the brooklyn area and uh i
know this was like local i believe he's
also based in brooklyn uh but after
watching the show i was kind of like
huh i'm not against doing that i drive
for a living like i do grub hub and
doordash and postmates and all that kind
of stuff little side hustle in the car
already
yeah yeah i'm in the car already so i'm
figuring you know just whatever to get
those hours up to get that money up uh
and so i reached out to him uh sadly i
was i was a little facetious with him so
i didn't actually get uh to the point
where i was sending him videos uh but i
do have a great
hotmail conversation uh that i can read
you guys if you want yeah so like how
much they pay and all that i definitely
want to hear it i'm gonna just refresh
the recruit people to barefoot drive
yeah so this is running as a show out of
his feet on youtube barefoot
brothersdrive.com
have a good time i will pay you to make
a bunch of videos and upload them to
site you can make money i can make money
this is a fun it's a fun win-win my
dudes enjoy happy birthday get in touch
with me through my youtube channel s
foot continuation or you can contact me
uh through my website or you can also
contact me this is the best ad youtube
ever ran i mean i just love that they
were you know they approved this they're
like this is good sure this doesn't this
is good this is good
okay so tell me about the process how
did you get in touch with them
yeah so um i emailed his hotmail um
which i'm
continuously tackling uh that it's a
hotmail account
so well yeah i think my parents are some
of them someone i know uses hotmail
still so
i reached out i reached out to his
hotmail and um i i texted him i was i
said like hey uh this is i said my name
i said kind of where i was located what
i do i just kind of explained the whole
situation to him i didn't say anything
about the podcast i didn't say anything
about where i came from because i
figured that a lot of people are
probably bombarding him with similar
things
uh and he just emailed me back just a
phone number and um
uh and i said hey this is liam or then i
said my email i just talked to you about
the possibility of me driving for you
guys
um he responded hi liam yes how old are
you which you know uh
respect that question responsible legend
yeah
yeah uh more than james charles
food delivery all that kind of stuff i i
uh kind of refilled him on this uh and
he goes 18 is a good age for me what
kind of car do you have liam do you
drive manual or automatic wow
so
you know we wanted to know if i had a
clutch she wanted to know
just kind of what my feet would be doing
down there
well you know this guy takes the [ __ ]
seriously
there's a lot more action going on
there's a lot more action yeah they're
harder to find yeah
but you probably drive auto right
yes i do i do yeah uh and so i i kind of
i give him the sad information i said hi
uh yes i i drive an automatic car and i
told him my car type
um
he goes sound good liam we pay 50 for
one hour video of you driving your and
then he said my car type it must be 1080
video and have audio
um
audio is important and all this kind of
stuff i i was kind of at this point
running to my car and figuring out if
there was a way that i could set up a
1080 camera to record my feet while i
was also driving yeah that's it that's
it and i i even went up
yeah i went out to the store and got a
little rig for the camera and everything
um doesn't sound like you're gonna be
making much money from this
well fifty dollars an hour i mean you
know what he had to go by
oh right he's out
his investment true true true
yeah exactly um
um anyways i got this whole rig got this
camera and everything uh and he stopped
responding to me uh i said okay sounds
good um i said sometimes my feet are
dirty is that okay uh just kind of
joking around with him um and he i said
sometimes they're super smelly too i can
talk about that on the audio if you'd
like um kind of i i regret doing this
because i feel like i could have gone
farther in
giving you guys more information and
maybe you've actually done this
um and then he says and this is the last
text he sent me he says liam i take
videos of you seriously if you don't
take my video club serious i don't want
to buy with you
um
i would figure the smelly stinky dirty
feet would be he would be into that
but
i thought i thought that was gonna sell
me more that's what i figured too agreed
yeah
i said oh no i take this seriously i
assure you please let me know how i can
you know kind of show you how serious i
am um i was like i can record a video
for you tonight um i actually and this
is very fun i can send uh zach or dan
the picture i actually also got like uh
colored led lights for my car uh for the
nighttime shots and everything
definitely
um gotta do exactly
so how much i can send that to you guys
so how much have you invested and set it
in and recording this video for him
like 75 dollars so 75 so and he stopped
he stopped responding to you
yeah yeah
so what i said i think you should say
dude
i spent 75 dollars investing in this i
demand the freaking response i mean i'm
out 25 bucks i need that 50 recoup yeah
no
i i feel and my thing is is that like
this was
90
a joke but like if it had gone fully
through and he stayed true to his word
and gave me fifty dollars an hour to do
this like
i i would probably actually do it it's
good
hold on hold on yeah no it's great money
hold on he said fifty dollars for an
hour video he's not saying go drive for
ten hours and i'll give you 500 bucks
so no i like one i i
if that was the case i probably would go
do that yeah
maybe i'll hire you to do that
i'll get a whole fleet of dudes out
there driving
around filming their feet
we put it on ethan's feet we put it on
when i when i die someday i'm just gonna
have it on a hard drive just to confuse
the hell
um anyways so i finished off the text
and i said um well uh his name is
michael or at least that's what he said
that's what his email linked to like if
you email him you know sometimes it'll
have their name yeah
uh it said his name was michael and i
don't know if he said his name in the
video or not but i i i called him
michael um
i said well michael i take this very
seriously please let me know how i can
continue uh so that way i can be a
member of this uh prestigious club uh so
he's yet to respond to me but this i
also just i just uh i sent that text
three hours ago uh so you know it's not
impossible um i'll send him a text um
telling him that i spent 75 dollars on
the rig and yeah you gotta help me
because you know send him a picture send
him a picture of all the [ __ ] you buy
you got the led yeah i mean he said i
take this very seriously i got to be
like me too
i take it incredibly seriously
send him a photo of all the stuff you
bought with receipts
and be like dude like i don't know how
much more i can prove to you that i'm
serious about this but like no i don't
know
i'm desperate yeah no this is a good
idea this is a good idea so let us know
i will do this and i will see if i can
get michael's attention uh and if i do
and i go any further with this i can
call back uh next week yeah please do
yeah you let us know i want to know but
it's like dude your commercial worked
i'm calling in yeah and you're treating
me exactly no
like
i guess i guess the commercial was
successful he's probably got a lot of
people
trying to cash in on no i especially
after the exposure on the podcast i'm
sure that there were a couple people who
found that as inviting as i did yeah
well get good luck and if he doesn't if
he doesn't take you up on it i'll give
you the 50 bucks for the video but i
want the video i'm not just giving out
charity here yeah no no no i i would 100
give you the video okay all right so try
to work it out with him and then come
back to us and and if not i'll i'll pay
you for the video i'll buy it from you
okay we'll do it thank you so much
i got you liam all right you take care
buddy
yeah i mean the man deserves
pay
fair pay for fair work yeah
that's what we're about here on the h3
podcast
i'm just looking at this trending by the
way on tick on twitter
wait where'd it go it was just here it
said keemstar retiring
yeah do you hear the news well hold on
hold on uh let me okay here it is social
media personality keemstar says he's
retiring all right i'll first of all
i'll believe it when i see it
look i know a lot of people let me just
watch this um
yeah i mean obviously i mean nobody
[ __ ] cares and everyone thinks he's a
creep which he is
he's exposed himself in the most like
crazy like
like i said before he exposed himself
like nobody ever could
oh here's a clip of us just that's love
oh that's you love
yep
yeah i still think he's trolling because
he's definitely trolling i don't believe
it i don't buy it
but he's still kind of roasting himself
because he he's never gotten that many
likes on a tweet before
true
yeah yeah and he's trending or and the
comments are great here's a video i'll
show it look i know but uh well here
ethan where you at yeah i know
here
here's the video look i know a lot of
people think i'm trolling a lot of
people think it's just bait that i'm
retiring
but i am retiring i know i've said a
million times that i'm never leaving the
internet but i'm never retiring
yeah but i really like a week ago
a week ago he's like [ __ ] all you haters
i will always be here i will never be
defeated you all think you can cancel me
i will win in 30 years everyone will
realize that being racist and
anti-semitic and homophobic
will be back in
defamation will be back in and everyone
will remember that i'm the king um i'm
going to
have a statement today on dramaalert to
talk about it briefly
um
you know things need to be
explained right like why i'm leaving
nope
nope just leave
nobody needs an explanation bro we get
it
oh drama alert
oh this is from 2018 with the first time
he got like mega cancelled after dude he
had he like idubbbz made the video and
then his two buddies
uh
grade a and leafy both turned on him and
started me it was cr it was pretty
[ __ ]
[Music]
even when that was happening though i in
a way felt bad for keemstar and that it
was like
leafy and grade a
because he really thought they were
friends and like i was like damn those
guys really are pieces of [ __ ] like even
the keemstar who i [ __ ] despise as a
person
and he and he reaped what he sowed but
that was some high level like uh
julius caesar brutus backstabbing
[Music]
i [ __ ] up you follow that ap you
remember that or i do yeah i do was that
around the time you went on baited or
was that
no
no no no no no that was after that okay
yeah
wait bring back the tweet i didn't read
it
roll it
i think that tweet
like two years after the drama you're
describing so he's saying i'm officially
retiring from youtube i'm not going to
upload videos and get 50 less views
because of broken youtube that's exactly
what he said he's bitching about now the
video last night is only 400k low that's
[ __ ] impossible for my channel easy
one mill by now buy hoes okay well
people loved it then 35 000 likes
probably his most liked tweet ever and
guess what his views are just as [ __ ]
now because uh he canceled him when he
exposed himself
for not only being a creep but also
being uh extremely cringe
bye-bye yeah the biggest crime that you
can do on the internet
and ross aiden ross the chosen one eight
of ross nobody gives a [ __ ] balance to
the force yes yeah
adam ross
did what no one else could my friends
yeah i thought it was immediately a
troll or it's about his views he's going
to leave for a little bit
and then come back hoping that it helps
or have another excuse as to why he's
not doing good i know he always keeps
talking about getting a new host on
drumline i hope he does that'll be such
a disaster
i think i can hear its video uh what's
gonna happen to the future of dramaalert
uh nobody cares you know what i'm gonna
do in retirement all the time i'm the
only one that cares i'm the only one
that's interested in i know somebody
yeah
i am very interested in his uh very
happy and excited to see my ass go
congrats to you
shut up
um
and i know others will be sad um but you
know
13 years how many uh january next year
will be 14 years
it's been a long time and i started my
youtube career
when i was like 27 it's late to get into
the game so
um
yeah
what did um danny do or what did uh john
peshi say in his famous song joe pesci
joe pesci
eat out my ass no no no it's the what
it's the what's that'll get you it's a
bitch's name
he played around with these young girls
and they ruined him man look at it
that's
uh i do disagree though i think it's the
aidan thing 100
i don't know it's everything i mean it's
like
like
he has been absolutely
domed by
by criticism like like the aiden thing
is one thing that hit at the heart of
his fans
true but the young girl like the amount
of press and rounds that made around
social media is one about like
36 year old women uh nice try all these
ugly girls no not in a chance that's
true that one
i saw all over the place in places
especially are totally outside of like
youtube yeah
he's he's [ __ ] yeah and like not to
mention that one of the girls who he
clowned on for being ugly is it was
actually like someone murdered by their
spouse in a missing
right yeah i think two of them were
missing yeah yeah two of them were
missing so
you know
oh man
yeah obviously i have a lot of choice
words for keemstar but i don't want to
like
if he's really retiring i'll definitely
be giving a eulogy
but uh let's see because i like wait and
see yeah exactly yeah we'll get through
it but you said that drum alert was up
didn't you love
yeah but he just deflected and said he's
gonna do a full video on it tomorrow
yeah
you want a ulg now look i know a lot of
people think i'm trolling i was
no because there's like ninety percent
sure and then you need to be like
goddamn oh
let's see here let's read some comments
wait and see wait and see
the world after keemstar retired
careful about
yeah does this really help what it
looked like is this really what it
looked like this oh okay
oh yeah because yeah that's a good point
people post very not safe for work
things in the replies to keep stuff
blaze who the [ __ ] face
spank
blaze
many phases too many phases i'm going
carefully
yeah so you i'll give you like uh i
don't know if this is going to occur
here let me encourage you to leave the
internet keemstar
um
you are without a doubt
one of if not the worst person i've ever
known on or off the internet
i thought you were going to go the
opposite reverse psychology route and
say please please stay
no because if you if you're saying this
i feel like this pushes him towards not
well i don't care i mean it's content
for me also his fingers on the trigger
he's waiting to report
yeah well [ __ ] him he can report all he
wants did
i give a [ __ ] about him or anything he
does at this point he's a little [ __ ]
neutered [ __ ]
he's just a nobody
and that's why he's leaving if he had
anything he'd stay
so
you are one of the worst people i've
ever known
uh you treat the news
as your personal um
attack show
you know you have
you there's something seriously wrong
with you dude like the smallest slight
turns into a personal vendetta that you
will go to any lengths to ruin that
person
um
you know
lying about me being a a scammer has has
consequences reverberated throughout the
years throughout my career even those
guys that made the jordan peterson
h3 made fun of jordan peterson uh
uh trigger
video we're saying about how i stole
fupa money
wait really yeah that's what abs right
yeah yeah
yeah and that's what i'm saying it's
like god that's the immortal jamari said
it too
his video was old to be fair to him
everyone was saying it back then
i suppose that's true
um you've you've literally ruined lives
from etika
one of the most horrendous
ways i've ever seen anybody uh treated
in the history of the internet
i hope that you carry guilt and shame
for the rest of your life
[ __ ] i mean like absolute [ __ ] like
shame and disgust like just horrific
shame um shame
bash traverse
literally destroyed that man
and then made fun of him after he died
and when he recently died of covid i
mean uh
you basically tap dance on his grave
yeah
which is i mean you you
you know back all the way to when you
falsely accused tony of being a
pedophile
um and just uh and just even all the
small ones that we don't talk about on a
weekly basis you just
um
you're just malicious you're a malicious
person and the only and i do feel like
the only reason people are nice or
tolerate you is because they don't want
you to go after them and try to ruin
their life
um you harassed me and my wife
you said my wife looks like a horse and
you encouraged all of your
little goon squads to harass her in the
same way you harassed abs wife called
her a witch
when he only had a few hundred followers
um
i'm busted
you're just really not a good dude
i hate to tell you this and i have said
it before but i i genuinely think that
at this point in time keemstar this is
the best thing for you to do
is step away
and you know we won't even notice you're
gone that's the thing except for me
because i you know
i enjoy the [ __ ] show
we hate keemstar
and also you're going to want to change
this to l king because here it says one
king so you want to change that to l
king
since you're leaving like a little
[ __ ]
you you look you lose sir
big l on my part um you
and and maybe just shape just start over
shave your beard
maybe get a hair transplant become a new
person
he's been banned from youtube like five
times i don't know how he still has a
channel
and uh basically
i'm basically hitler
um
you know he's he's
and also frankly i have a better
hairline than you
i didn't ask for this okay
it's just what god gave me
[Music]
now if that's gonna make you upset
here let me take off my beanie look at
that [ __ ]
it's godly
that's a god-tier hairline my dude
i didn't ask for this
and i just find it ironic too because
keemstar would always go on and on like
when all the drama he would harass me
the dm's and just torment me and be like
one of you someone he was obsessed with
this notion of someone someone's gonna
leave there's not enough space on
youtube it's either gonna be you me or
leafy or pyro and he was always obsessed
with like
someone's gonna [ __ ] leave and get
canceled and their channel's gonna die
and i don't care about any of that [ __ ]
i'm just out here doing my thing but it
looks like you're the one that [ __ ]
in the end is taking the l
uh
damn except probably not because it's
probably just a troll yeah well he's
still taking the l because like i mean
let's be honest
his views are way down
and even when he clickbaited that he was
going to be retiring he's still not
getting any views
i mean he gets good views
[Music]
oh what happened
here let me just downvote this real fast
yeah
so anyway
yeah i
and you know there's not many people in
the world that i dislike like genuinely
he might be one of the only
that i can genuinely say like yeah this
this is just a bad dude
but at least if you leave the internet
you can go date 18 year olds in peace
you know
although they won't have much of a
reason to be with you
keemstar shut up
unless you buy them stuff and
give them money
which is a good reason i guess with him
over with his
charming personality perhaps
anyway let's see what he has to say but
yeah keemstar is a piece of [ __ ] and uh
we'd all be better if he was off the
internet
in fact i wouldn't even be opposed to a
court order of uh you know how sometimes
the court says no internet access
so i wouldn't even be a poster
what
yeah ruger stone style
oh roger stone can't use the internet
maybe he can now but he was he was
ordered off the internet that's awesome
yeah he's basically
yeah they do that to predators sometimes
too like oh no internet for you so
i'd be interested in exploring that
option too um if you want
uh we need to do
some advertisements
we're an hour in already oh [ __ ] yes sir
let's do it thank you to mint we love
mint mobile i love i love i love a mint
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers if we've learned anything is
that there's always a catch and when i
first heard that mint mobile offers
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month i thought what's
the catch
but after speaking with them and using
their service it all made sense there
isn't one mint mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless services online only and by
cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs that get passed
down to you in the form of mysterious
fees instead mobile just passes on the
suite savings directly to you
listen dan's been using it indeed it
works great it's the same [ __ ] it's the
same better because it's way cheaper
exactly
and what's funny is they use the same
network
they say here
that um
all plans come with unlimited talk and
text and high-speed data delivered on
one of the nation's largest 5g network
they all use the same network that's the
irony
it's the same service just cheaper
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month use your phone
with any mint mobile plan and keep your
same phone number along with all your
existing contacts and if you're not 100
satisfied mobile has you covered with
their 7 day money back guarantee switch
to mint mobile and get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month to get your new wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com h3tv that's
mintmobile.com slash h3tv cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
midmobile.com h3tv thank you thank you
peace and love peace and love peace and
love
quip
guys when it comes to brushing your
teeth there's no substitute for the best
that's why i only use quip
first of all let me tell you quips got
the soft brush heads
knocks the competition out of the game
you i guaran i challenge you to go to
like a grocery store or wherever and
find a toothbrush with soft brush heads
they're always so freaking hard i tear
my gums up
and i'll tell you what your gums don't
grow back once you damage those things
they just recede recede recede and then
you're effed
so that's the first thing i love about
the second thing is that they vibrate
dentists all agree that vibrating
toothbrush give a better brush
but also pulsates to tell you when to
move on to the next quadrant so you got
30 seconds 30 seconds 30 seconds 30
seconds to ensure that you get that
perfect two-minute dentist recommended
brush that's what it's all about
uh the quip electric toothbrush is loved
by over seven million mouths dude they
are taking over
it's lightweight it's sleek there's no
wires or bulky chargers
um you know they've got a reusable
handle
in black and pink
and on top of the brushing you can
upgrade your equip with a new smart
motor to help track and improve your
brushing with free quip app and you can
earn rewards like free refills products
target gift cards and more
you know beyond the brush clip is
everything you need to build a complete
routine
they've got anti-cavity toothpaste and
mint and watermelon that helps prevent
cavities and they've also got floss
floss strings that ex that expands to
clean and reasonable reusable floss pick
that replaced over 180 disposable picks
with every refill that's good
yeah we love quilt folks
if you can if you go to get quick dot
com slash h3tv right now you'll get your
first refill for free that's your first
refill free at get quip dot com slash
h3tv spell g-e-t q-u-y-p dot com slash
h3 tv quip the good habits company thank
you
and finally we love you honey
we all shop online
we've all seen that promo code feel
taunting us to check out but thanks to
honey manual searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds to your cart hunting supports
over 30 000 stores online ranging from
tech gaming products popular fashion
brands and even food delivery
here's how it works imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
and when you check out the honey button
drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupon you wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
you can find for the site if uh honey
finds a working coupon then the price
drops magically
i love honey i use it on all my browsers
it's free it's easy to install
it's just a
you know a browser extension and when
you're shopping online
you're at the checkout
it automatically searches for coupons
that's it you know you don't even have
to think about it dude exactly
and like me and either routinely save
like 50 bucks 30 bucks even you know 10
bucks but it adds up man for example
they've saved
17 million people 2 billion dollars bruh
if you don't already have honey you can
be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free installs in
a few seconds and by getting it you're
going to be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this podcast i would never
recommend something i don't use so for
that reason i do use and recommend honey
go to honey
get honey for free at jointhoney.com
h3tv that's joinhoney.com
h3tm thank you
thank you thank you thank you good job
on those ads ethan thank you
thank you so much celebrities
getting through it baby
so um
oh we have a game oh we're not done with
keemstar we have a well we kind of we
just
we ended up getting to it before we got
to it in the dark i think the only thing
probably worth looking at is this right
here because it's pretty funny
yeah we have a conspiracy that every
time we talk about him our videos go
yellow which almost doesn't happen these
days we've gotten really good at kind of
understanding around the scene
but somehow whenever we talk about him
like i'm sure
i'm sure
that he's writing what emails every time
we talk about him well it didn't end up
going yellow last time though it got
flipped yeah it did get flipped but it
may have been someone reviewed it was
like ah this is fine yeah perhaps but
what did you want to show me this put a
cap on the meme star i got it
highlighted
oh this oh my dad's getting involved oh
no
he responded in the thread too he posted
again uh
did he really yeah i didn't see that let
me uh yeah you should find it just go to
his
his uh tweets i am retiring full
statement later today liked by gary
klein smash that like button
when we saw it he had already uh he had
already done it here let's see
yeah he had a reaction gift under there
of like people cheering
oh here it is
you want to make a
yeah there's my dad uh
here wait no that's not my dad it's
under that oh oh he replied to that
you guys want to make a
prediction for his why did he do that
one god he's such a boomer
such a boomer meme
you guys want to make predictions for
what will be in his retirement video
that could be fun and then we can do
like bingo my prediction is that there
won't be a retirement video because he's
trolling just no retirement video i
don't there's he's got to be doing about
something something about him getting
old i don't buy it
something he's going to have another
another person hosts the show
yeah for a little while that will be a
disaster no one will care
i really think he's done that
i think he's putting in his boots man
i think that he well usually what he
does is he'll leave for a few months and
then come back
so here's what will happen he'll find
some random person he's not threatened
by this not that entertaining just
enough to basically
it's true because he doesn't want to
build someone up that's gonna like like
deaf noodles you know who can build
their own fan base and then eventually
turn on them because he's a piece of
[ __ ]
i'm laughing because it's so spot on
that's why yeah it's so accurate yeah so
he's find someone like mid-tier
entertaining that's not threatening to
him just enough to float the channel for
a few months didn't he post somebody
else's content on his video recently
yeah [ __ ] or on his uh channel yes he
did yeah
so maybe
maybe you're right and then he'll get
like
someone mid tier
i didn't watch that one
i'm only interested in kim
daniel kame content
what'd you say love
i said he's had other hosts before
long time yeah when the last time he was
like i'm retiring he brought in some
other dude who's like disappeared i
don't know who he is no not mood oh
mother did it immediately
so i find it so weird
wait really that happened
oh yeah was it
okay i was gonna say wait is that guy
still doing videos uh love
i think he got cancer for something
[Laughter]
that's how kim operates he brings them
in knowing he can cancel them when
they're done so he can they can't
yeah he hasn't uploaded in eight months
he's the king of cancer culture
yeah so he's gonna bring someone out
it's gonna be a disaster for three
months he's gonna say basically that
yeah he's too old
he's talking about charlie dimigio and
all this [ __ ] and he's just too old for
the game
he's been in the game for too long
he might complain about youtube not
showing his videos
and then when he comes back and he's not
getting the views he can blame it on
just coming back
right so the cycle can help definitely
come back though that that's for sure
but i think actually the retiring thing
might be real
it's just he's not serious because he
knows he's going to come back in a few
months
um
what else might he say
yeah that's about it
i just found out who was replacing me
when i tired this is from 2019 just
before you bought racer
hey keemstar you are a bitch-ass [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] and i hope that the world
knows this you sit by the computer all
day but i promise you one day you won't
be and i will be there is that a threat
or he's just saying
congratulations to bot racer everybody
the new host is dramaalert
excited for that
yeah so i don't know i'm curious though
i'm waiting i'm watching i don't i don't
think all hope is gone for keemstar
though he can repeat can he be
rehabilitated
if he just takes a long retreat i know
dennis literally just had a seizure he
stroked out his eyes rolled so far back
in his head
i don't want to be all negative here
maybe in a lobotomy could help
i don't believe they uh do those anymore
but maybe they'll make an exception
for our boyd for our boy daniel
yeah he pains me that he's a fellow
daniel
well he's just disservice to the name
good strong name otherwise
well we've got some long form content i
want to watch um
channel 5 put out a new video which was
great
william osmond i wanted to watch that
one
i guess william osman daniels
daniel keems
retiring
you want to watch williams or channel 5.
i'm curious to watch williams i i didn't
i know that he
i know the context of it but i i haven't
actually seen the video yet so
yeah what's interesting about williams
video is i watched a bit of it
and i was like dude this is like
everything that i've been through it's
crazy
uh i hope he's not actually retiring
though because he's so talented
i think he's got to go down the meme
hole there's like a whole
um youtuber's journey where it's like
this isn't my first rodeo
where it's like you have to kind of
disengage
um let's watch channel five though maybe
to lighten up the mood and then we'll
bring it back down with william okay
sounds good yeah that's a good point
yeah we're gonna it's like a roller
coaster of emotions here we bring it up
we bring it down it's like a good dj
once we get dj i gotta pee though does
oh oh that's me i was like wait did
someone expose me i was like that's me
i
did oh that's funny do you get nervous
every time you see your face in the
thumbnail
i know i'm used to it honestly like i
sometimes these days well there was a
time when there was like every [ __ ]
commentary channel was making a video
every it was just like the easiest views
in the world for some reason everybody
agreed that i was just the sk the worst
dude that ever lived but you see that
the commentary channels go after
one person and then everyone see what
gets traction they just yeah they all
just want to repeat what goku narrow did
because he went from 10k to like 200k
quickly and so they just ripped him off
whatever happened to goku now he stopped
posting videos i mean you were in
contact with them yeah we were we're
cool i mean he
traitor
honestly
yeah no it was fine that he
kind of i mean i'm not saying that this
is why but he sort of disappeared after
we made a response to him and then he
made a response to the response and then
that was just kind of the last item yeah
he wanted to move on from the situation
he didn't want to be known for that
video he was doing some kind of uh sorry
he was doing like a documentary yeah he
released like the first part and then i
don't know what happened and then he
just dipped maybe he's a political
prisoner in china maybe he went to china
to the hong kong protest did he really
that's what his video was on yeah
that was his last show
nobody's nobody's looking into that
everyone cared about brian laundry but
nobody care about gunking
okinawa do a wellness check on it maybe
anyway whatever i'm over all that [ __ ]
yeah
but like no i don't i don't i just go
like oh wow another one you know because
it's like
i've been a good boy i mean i i've been
since this is such a good boy ever since
those videos except for making fun of
jordan peterson yeah then like if i see
someone be like oh ethan called out
jordan peterson i'm like well yeah okay
fine
you know that's fine if you want to get
mad for that that's fine what i what
really bothered me then was i just felt
like
i was i was drowning in a sea of lies
and slander
but like if you're gonna hate me at
least hate me for something i actually
did yeah i mean when i watched the
original video i was even like how long
have you been online and this is all
they have like what this is
i don't know there's a bunch of
speculation and
uh
you want to make a video about that and
finally
maybe i'll make a video i'm a good boy
oh god
i don't know if now it's the moment
for once yeah
wow
you're crazy like i'm a good boy i'm a
good boy but the godfather wouldn't say
that well the godfather isn't a boy good
man you're a good boy you're a good boy
for hill
take him out to the lake and show him a
good time
for you to go you're a good boy
your heart was in the right place fly up
to hong kong have a show him a good time
take him out on the lake
[Music]
keemstar you're a good boy
you tried your best
take keemstar out in the woods
out in the buffalo
lots of woods in buffalo place could get
lost a man could get lost
you know lots of lakes in buffalo a guy
could get lost out there
[Laughter]
just kidding
i gotta pee you guys want to read some
donuts or something i'll bear back sure
yeah we had that one don't know um for
two hundred dollars
that
didn't um
are you high sorry ethan just tripping
over [ __ ] are you high dude what the
[ __ ]
you're [ __ ]
high that's true
um yeah somebody donated 200 bucks
without a message and then another that
same person donated a hundred dollars
and then left a message so i guess to
300 total hi crew i love you guys so
much you're the best part of my week and
got me through some hard times peace and
love and papa bless that is very sweet
and glad to get you through some hard
times uh 300 is a lot of money i'm i'm
sorry how you pronounced him
[Music]
uh i sent it in the amelie amelie amelie
emily for 300 bucks we got at least
attempt to say emily
mayer or meyer probably mayor
[Music]
sorry sorry
that's a lot of money to be
mispronouncing your name so i am sorry
uh
50
from destiny vega can i have advice uh
well you were probably asking
ethan and he's not here so i apologize i
had some advice on how to speak out
against injustice against me
my ex-husband are worded and s-a'd me oh
sorry
uh
when we were both in the military and
got not guilty even though he confessed
i'm looking for help in real life i want
to share my story on social media
when it comes to stuff like that going
on in the military
that's like such a it's a whole
different ball game from from what i
understand i mean i'm not ex-military
but i know it's uh
unfortunately unbelievably common in the
military and it gets very much
swept under the rug
i mean i don't know if i have any advice
to tell you the truth
as far as getting
traction on it i suppose try and
contact news media in the area where you
guys were stationed or something to try
and get them to report on it would
be my my only thought but that's
terrible i'm sorry that happened to you
and yeah unfortunately that uh
happens a lot in the military
um
aaron donated 20 and said can you guys
do a halloween costume fashion show i
don't know about a fashion show but this
friday we will all be dressed up baby do
you want to talk about why you're in a
halloween costume today and nobody else
is yeah i was trying to get on for
office halloween party and i was like
you know what no one's gonna see it uh
on air so i might as well just rock it
and everyone we all do we all have
costumes for the halloween party
tomorrow wearing it no
this one this one's for the boys
and the girls the audience and the girls
why do i dwight everyone always says i'm
not the way around the office so maybe
will they say that about you
does that mean i'm michael scott yes
god actually funny enough though
that new that bidet in there sprayed me
when i went to the bathroom just like
this it's kind of water all over the
place yes sorry about that
when you walk in where's the
where's the button that's what i'm
saying i think cause someone had it on
just a little bit because it's just that
little silver part
and so i went to turn it off with the
wrong way like turn it yeah you just
turn it oh but i went the wrong way and
it got me am i the only one that's so
i hate i don't i don't mean to
decorate
efforts
because av put a lot of effort into
putting in these bidets yes
but does anyone find it kind of gross
like a communal bidet
well it doesn't touch the water no i
know like technically it's fine but
it's a little gross i don't want to know
that
the same but they just squirted dan's
ass like i'm not following that up
well
olivia's nodding yes i said that last
week and everybody looked at me like i
was crazy they were like no it doesn't
it doesn't touch any i would never use
it and i was like i don't want it really
never but like our asses all touch the
same seat
yeah i don't know i don't want to talk
about that
well i can't i can't handle the truth
i wouldn't i don't know why i'll just
never use that all right if you did that
everyone saw that nobody else i mean
olivia's with me but it's just us
doesn't bother me
i i don't i don't know why he would
bother what if a little poop squirted
into the bidet hole
the water is being ejected at a high
velocity in the opposite direction maybe
the water gets turned off exactly when
one poop projectile that's the price of
it all mine i think maybe your shit's at
a different caliber
theodore style blowouts yeah in there
let's watch this channel 5 video dude
channel 5 and crank him out
he just put out one
i was a week ago i guess not i thought
it was like three days ago
sorry i'm chewing
but anyway put you in the chew zone
don't do it don't you do it
don't you [ __ ] do the chew zone oh
well throw them in
i don't have the halloween background on
that one so i won't do it oh you can't
okay good
do it anyways anyway this was a great
one
you're in
[Music]
damn i would like to eat that ass
oh no okay
get him out of the cheese zone get him
out i would eat this i think you guys
regret that shoe zone
yeah so
um his homie
i don't know what actually they i don't
know if they ever explain what uhuru is
or maybe oh hey what's up swami
thank you what's going on i don't know
was that an important package
what'd you get
it's it's it's nothing important okay i
think because it's raining out he didn't
want it to get wet oh that's good sweet
guys
i love swamps
[Laughter]
he does this thing for some reason hold
up
okay sorry he does this thing for some
reason where he'll only communicate with
me and like everyone will be like maybe
he's knocking on the window again i'd be
like tell him to come in he's always
doing this
st where's abe yeah
you're the guy you're the man you're the
white ethan he referred you as frank
let's talk ethan's a hard name because
you know oh yeah no that's a tough one
well
i was
i was eddie for six months
eddie you know i love that he just gives
people names
he's our security guard he's a character
didn't he call me the girl with the hair
yeah
that's that's really true i hate you
could she move her car and i said who he
said the girl like which girl he goes
this one
legend [ __ ]
i mean he's not wrong it is although
i guess technically that would be work
for sam that would also work for sam
or ela or everyone at teddy
or cam even he has longer i can't see
anybody but me
not me
i've been pushing for a swami weekly
segment but i don't know
love
love rolls out in front and chats with
swami on the robot
i tried to one time he was standing
there and
he just didn't acknowledge me
were you saying his name yeah i was
hello and i like said like this i wonder
if he was scared
to be fair you are like just ignore me a
computer
maybe he doesn't know yeah he didn't
realize well we can set you up we can
set up a play date
okay thank you good to know each other a
little bit
yeah so it's a bunch of white people
that went to oakland
to rally for reparations of uh
the
descendants of slaves
but it takes this really weird slant
it's awesome anyway let's watch we can
discuss as well
everybody
meets freedom in swahili i just want to
welcome all of you today and thank all
of you for coming out to the march for
reparations to african people
i'm a descendant of settlers and i
believe in reparations in order to heal
our nation
and we need to address racially based
climate change in order to save our
planet in order to save this race and we
need to give reparations before we're
going to be able to heal anything
including our planet yeah
hey i appreciate you uh your heart's in
the right place
damn uh uhuru
breaking news
this guy is awesome by the way who
filled in for andrew
really good video
you're probably wondering what you're
watching i'm your host andrew callahan
and that footage was from the uhuru
reparations march on the streets of
oakland california at the time of this
rally i was a few hours south in
hollywood at an anti-vax march here we
are channel 5 live worldwide hollywood
and vine free to march but the night
before we caught wind of a very
important day the national day for
african reparations hosted by an
organization called uhuru solidarity
whose slogan is white solidarity with
black power
as white people we have always upheld
the lie that america is the home of
freedom and democracy but the reality is
very different long before trump at the
cries of fascism african people were
catching hell something is wrong with
this reality because every opportunity
and amenity i have uh has been
at the expense of my black and brown
brothers and sisters around the world
you owe money if you don't give it we're
going to come together
and i've seen prince take it all right
so while i was busy in hollywood at the
anti-vaxx rally we sent our african
studies correspondent saddam to the bay
area to figure out what the hell's going
on
is he wearing a green beanie like
because it looks so funny
oh and it's king out yeah
[Music]
we are here at snow park it's one of the
widest parks i've ever seen we're going
to see the uhuru solidarity movie it's a
bunch of white people that believe in uh
african reparations they want to give us
money so
let's get some money
do you guys believe in reparations
uh
kind of yes i think i think i do i mean
i guess it just depends on
how it's
how it's handled or whatever but in in
some form uh broadly i would say it's
probably a good idea
i never really thought about until like
the past year but
i'm 100 in favor of reparations well the
thing is is that like when
reconstruction happened in this country
they were essentially going to do
reparations then and it got completely
[ __ ] gutted and just yeah and stopped
and then they were supposed to get
hooked up each freed slave slave was
supposed to get a plot of land and some
money right
and then at the last minute they're like
[ __ ] that
what's uh
i'm blanking on his name the president
that stepped in after
lincoln got his head blown off basically
he was like [ __ ] blocked it yeah big
time yeah i mean
johnson
uh african-americans descendants of
slaves have
been absolutely f i've never even given
a chance to prosper
in this country from the minute they
were freed as slaves
to being denied loans um
you know to living in poor neighborhoods
where there's no property tax so the
schools suck
and um
yeah it's just a lot of [ __ ] piled
on year after year for
wealthier generational rights
wealth is generational so
i come from a middle-class family my
parents were able to pay for me to go to
college and give me opportunities and
only that but when you come from a
middle class family you live in a
you go to a decent school because again
it's it's all funded by property it's
public your school is likely going to be
a lot nicer
so you know and like wealth is
generational so
black americans were never able to even
buy houses because they weren't given
loans you know back in during jim crow
redlining after yeah redlining
um
so
i mean i i'm i'm not smart enough or i'm
not the person to know
what that would look like or but you
know broadly as a as an idea i think
it's probably a pretty good idea yeah
there's a reason that the like black
family's net worth is like one-tenth of
white people's and that's why you see
this
class divide
i think the first thing you could do is
fund their schools fund their
communities
[Music]
pay for college help them help them get
you know
uplift the community by providing good
education you know some people on the
left too say like no we shouldn't do
that because um subsidies for home loans
would be a great way to get in there
oh right yeah um
yeah and and and some people just say
like no you should make you know social
programs universal because if you don't
it will cause uh too much resentment and
well sure that i guess that's ideal
right but but they're they feel like it
is a unique circumstance they're
disadvantaged
they are literally disadvantaged and
what's most [ __ ] up about them being
so disadvantaged generationally is that
it perpetuates racial stereotypes about
all like
people use that to justify racial
stereotypes
don't work hard enough they're lazy
they're violent they're criminals it's
like no they're poor they're poor and
[ __ ] disadvantaged because they used
to be slaves
yeah i say i say [ __ ] reparations all
the way dude
the net worth of a typical white family
is nearly 10 times greater than that of
a black family
thank you you see i got a stat right hey
hey
we did it got him
hey [ __ ] i know what i'm
talking about now that said
like the guy said it seems like these
people's heart and in the right place
this seems pretty goofy no you see as it
unfolds because people are [ __ ] crazy
but as a concept you know i i think it's
a i think we should do it man too bad
it's run this country's run by a bunch
of white supremacists pretty much
i'm just hearing uh recently about
some individual organizations are
starting to just take it upon themselves
to do it i was hearing like a it was
actually a um
a uh a
monastery is that the right term abby a
place where a bunch of monks live
christian monks and basically during
slavery they
had slaves working on their property and
uh
you know working their their land and
everything
and they've just taken upon themselves
and they've
themselves tracked down the descendants
of
the individual slaves that worked on
their
um on their
again
priory is a nun thing
anyways it's not important but they are
uh yeah just cutting checks to the
descendants of the slaves that used to
work on the church so
shout out to
yeah the government is monetary yeah
that is cool thing that they're doing
but like yeah giving subsid giving good
preferred mortgages on loan on home home
loans and [ __ ] like that you know sure
that would go a long way
i you know a different take on this i
know um
over 90 year old man who was in
auschwitz he was an auschwitz survivor
and germany pays him
uh every month that's true holocaust
foreign yeah so he gets a fat check does
he how much does he get i don't know the
exact alarm out but i know is it fatty
like like millions no no i'd say it's in
the thousands
yeah
germany honestly those guys did a good
job in trying to turn a new leaf there
pretty impressive what they were how
they're able to rehabilitate
their country
and i mean they just they just [ __ ]
straight up slaughtered people and
america is still like yeah
anyway let's watch this
the united states of america was built
on stolen land and stolen labor the
african people socialist party was
putting forward the figure of 4.1
trillion dollars in unpaid labor it's
really about we as white people
confronting our proof hang on i got i
got a update here
in 1988 germany approved money for
holocaust survivors they would get 290 a
month come on
i was i was i was
290 a month germany come on now well in
what year 1988
do an inflation check on that
bro you killed all of us almost
you almost killed all of us and you only
get
300 bucks a month 1988 right but these
are people that were in the holocaust
come on germany step up
672 us that's something doo doo dog [ __ ]
right there boy
that is enough it's more than slaves in
america i mean it may have increased as
well i don't know i'm seeing there's a
lot of stuff going back and forth it's
like
i got to check for 300 bucks after being
in the holocaust and be like dog i was
in the holocaust
i mean if you want to pay fair labor
those guys literally worked
until they died literally
i mean come on cut a track here
anyway
privilege in this system and not just
confronting it ideologically but
confronting it actually by giving back
can i have five dollars
dee are you serious yes
you got change i love this
actually i don't sorry i don't sorry
okay
next time this is the best thing ever
yeah next next time
wait so did he give him the money or did
he not get the money oh
because well he said next time so maybe
not i yeah
i think you're like
you got to put your money where your
mouth is
yeah i don't think that's what
reparations is just asking white people
for money give me five bucks yeah what's
going on we're here uh marching for
reparations for african people we want
reparations how would you like to see
like reparations being used like in the
black community
i think that's up to the black people
and how they want to do it that's that's
true that's true
uh can i get five dollars of course
i only have a 20. uh does that work that
works yeah 30 schools thank you
i love you i love you
we're with the freedom socialist party
so we're a socialist feminist
anti-racist
international party um again can i get
five bucks that's so funny man it's
awesome coming from an anti-capitalist
perspective we do think that
redistributing the wealth
is going to need to happen for any
liberation to really happen hell yeah
can i have five dollars
that's not the the massive reparations
where it comes from matters and it needs
to be
paid by the people that have reaped the
benefits we are for reparations um you
know we are you know actually working on
a you know a pamphlet on what you know
the specifics should be
but reparations are a just demand you
know when you have people that were
stolen from their countries and then
tell them oh hey you're free now but
we're gonna still let people you know
discriminate against you you need to
make things right through reparations
and that's mega corporations and it is
the capitalist system and i don't think
it's yeah i'd give you five bucks if i
had it but i don't think it's for any
individual who's part of the working
class again i don't have it the way i
should have it under the system either
so it's not so it sounds like someone
who's making excuses
[Music]
pony up lady
much i don't think for any working class
or per person to provide that personally
but to be in a movement that's demanding
that that happen at a systemic level and
again tax the rich to get schools tax
the rich to make housing tax the rich to
pay for reparations that's where i would
come at it from
[Applause]
now
so right now
hello people gave speeches and now we're
marching to the furniture store the
uhuru furniture store so far i got 20
bucks
i would've got 25 but the dude didn't
have to change
some of these [ __ ] are just broke
my name is ali i yellow
from oakland california and or i'm not
from oakland california i've lived in
oakland california uh since uh february
of this year
and i'm from new jersey
yeah all right cool so uh what are we
doing here today
yeah so we're out here uh the
organization that's putting this on is
the uhuru solidarity movement where an
organization that works under the
leadership of the african people's
socialist party to organize particularly
in the way community for reparations to
after they're associated with
they're associated with african
social society or what is that i didn't
i didn't hear i'm reading
an organization that works under the
leadership of the african people's
socialists oh african people socialist
party to organize particularly in the
white community for reparations to
african people africa is the future it's
the youngest continent on the planet
there's so much potential there living
there it's so dynamic there's so much
opportunity it is literally the future
it will drive innovation from the youth
and from additional investment what are
three favorite things about africa oh
okay
i was in west africa and they joke a lot
with each other and so like if i'm tore
and you're [ __ ] bali yeah
i'd be like oh you eat beans and you'd
be like oh well you're my slave so
this lady gives me the weirdest vibes
she gives me like super weird vibes
and she does she seems to like fetishize
black people yeah it's very odd
yeah
cool weird example can i get five
dollars i don't have any cash but i can
venmo you i only got cash app oh i got
cash oh okay cool shout out catch up
cash app is the best service ever
channel five cash app game shout out
the best way to send reparations uh if
you're reincarnated would you be white
again
i want to say no
i would love to be like a part of the
black community like for real but i also
know that that's kind of like signing
myself up for issues in life but you
know
i don't know man i like loved being in
africa so like i would be very happy to
be like a west african like a mom i
don't know why but that question was so
good because
i just don't ever think about being born
black or anything else and
i just feel like
this lady is weird
she would love to be reborn black
specifically they're the best people
they're like so kind and cool and honest
yeah focal molly
oh do you live in oakland now
yeah i do yeah how long have you lived
out here two years
cool
so going into the rally i didn't know
what to expect i realized that most of
these people weren't even from oakland a
lot of these people was from like
virginia well boston santa cruz san
diego and the thing about oakland is
it's a majority black city right was it
chocolate city as some people would say
is that what they said
that's what they used to call cities
like chocolate cities or something like
that it was a majority black population
but uhuru's platform for reparations
does not address anything in the bay
area all the money collected at that
march was supposedly going to the
construction of a basketball court in st
louis missouri [ __ ] love basketball
though but that's not really going to
uplift the community as much as like
some type of educational institution uh
something that'll help people out like
free lunch programs the basketball court
seems kind of redundant to me especially
if you're in oakland so oakland has
become one of the hottest rental markets
in the bay area now people who've lived
in the city for decades are getting
pushed out well the reality of
gentrification is hitting oakland's
lgbtq community tonight the building
that serves as headquarters for oakland
pride has been sold to a real estate
firm me and my daughter got rejectified
to north richmond spacious lofts in turn
of the century victorians west oakland
has been a hot spot for local artists
and musicians it's kind of a
quintessentially west oakland kind of a
space the mayor of oakland announced
she's creating a special cabinet to look
at housing and affordability according
to the east bay equity atlas oakland's
black community has decreased by 25
percent in the past 10 years and 91
percent of low-income homes of color are
currently in areas that are actively
gentrifying or about to gentrify this is
a result of big tech's takeover of the
bay area which has caused home prices to
rise while wages for the working class
have remained the same i mean we should
look and see how many basketball courts
are in st louis
yeah so they're collecting money to
build a basketball court in saint louis
which on faith seems like a very racist
kind of weird stereotype
yeah exactly
and that was really funny to pull up
like yeah there's look how many
basketball courts are there it's so
weird
it just seems extremely racist to me i
don't know
a group of all white people go to
historically one of the blackest cities
in california the home of the black
panthers and um they want to collect
money from other white people but like
not marching through white neighborhoods
and um build a basketball court so we
can ball it
outside the country
the people who donated money will never
be able to see [ __ ] that might come out
of here i don't know i don't think
reparations is building basketball
courts i don't think so i think it's
more
a little bit deeper than that
i mean who knows
if michael jackson then didn't oh [ __ ]
if the next kobe bryant
[Laughter]
come out saint louis missouri from the
uguru solidarity basketball court nobody
in oakland will be able to be like i
seen that kid i grew up with him
so you know we decided to see what's up
with people from the town actually from
the community well all i heard was white
solidarity i said i better get the hell
out of here
i didn't know what that meant
what are your opinions on reparations
i agree with it i mean
as a people we've been through a lot
yeah i mean
all we can do is state our case
you know what i mean just like with
anything with laws and you know
rights you know and hopefully uh
congress or or our local officials will
step in and you know
and help out with that kind of a thing
hopefully you think white people are
evil no i ain't saying no i'm not saying
that i'm just saying some of them are
but some of them are not you think they
owe us money though i think they should
somebody should uh
you know give a little something back
i think they do as a start i think that
every black person in america
deserves the right to know where we come
from our ancestry and could be done with
a dna from our government it would again
give us
knowledge it will empower us to know who
we are i got an eminem hat on bro i have
an embarrassing let's go
where do we come from the slave trade
everything was lost
and the government owes us to us as some
people to know where we come from what
are your thoughts on reparations i think
ideally it is owed but
in reality i don't believe that it will
happen how do you put an amount on and
where do you where does it start and
where does it stop so how do you
calculate i miss
america will be bankrupt
right what if i just start asking white
people for money no
absolutely not
i think that's a federal a government
thing we just could start asking you
know
anything i got 20 so far
bye
reparations is not gonna be you know
some sort of welfare check from the u.s
government because how could
a welfare check or some sort of payout
or something like that ever meet the
dollar amount that's been stolen from
african people how do you define what
george foye's life was worth you know in
terms of the culture that he brought to
the family his role as a father and what
he brought to his community
so who controls where all the money goes
when y'all collect reparations the
furniture store um
i think it's a great way that the first
time it's funny
they also have great stuff like i've
bought a lot of stuff from here oh my
god these people are so weird
what does the furniture store do with
the money
well
i don't know exactly how they use the
money but i think they use it for
like the same kind of thing that we're
marching for today to to build resources
um and to invest in the black community
in the us yeah with basketball court
does it go to the uh the basketball
court
this is my first time volunteering
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
congratulations
that's a great video wow you guys really
know how to like
frame a topic and edit it up fantastic
stuff such great content
that was super funny too
yeah man i'm all for reparations it's
exciting that uh he has um
some other
anchors uh
and by the way he can go out and kind of
do what he does because he's so good at
it that it i'm sure it's not easy to
find other people that can that's what i
was gonna say like not only that but
that guy did a great job so the fact
that he can fill in other ink and
there's so much going on we need 10
andrews yes by the way love said pokeman
just became a member
yes sorry
you know it's the real pokey
with a check mark what up pokey bring
her in
pokey get on a call
didn't we add her on discord or
something
you know i think i actually yeah i have
her as a friend she sent a alfredo emoji
you know alfredo has a really high score
on ethan's feet cookie she says she's a
fupa trooper woo
we love pokey
she's a she's a great one class act
i'm a fan pokey
um there i don't know if you want to
chat or you just want to watch so i
don't know you don't have to call in
maybe you don't want to
um
andrew callahan said who's keemstar a
little crossover here what is this memes
colliding
interesting
we're going to talk about keemstar
retiring in a second what do you think
about that who's keemstar damn he
doesn't know
you're a well-adjusted person is that
like a a streamer automatically you're
just [ __ ] why are these guys
dressed like they're like why are these
guys dressed like they're in antarctica
i mean it's literally called drama he's
like
what's the
you can hear it ruffling like
he's ready for like
sub freezing like yeah i know it's
raining but what's the temperature right
now
weather i'll tell you it's cold in here
and i'm wearing a [ __ ] 57 degrees now
i can't go oh [ __ ] that's that's chilly
okay i'm not going to hate now uh update
pokey sent three alfredos oh three
alfredo three alfredo's wow i said you
did that
she said we did at her dan
okay so
you just said
she can call in if she wants to well
you're trying to get a pressure on
discord well
[Music]
if you're down to call in
send 10 10 20 alfredo's in chat
and then we'll know no pressure
wait till i get my how was he using that
jay-z song i think it could be or was
that kanye he pitched it up
you think that worked i just won't find
out kanye yeah sorry ann it's actually
yay now yay
so we watched that one that was fun we
have another long-form one what was it
the um
what was it we had a sad one it was the
william
oh yeah let's watch that actually i'm
really curious
i don't watch that one
where'd it go
yes sir william osman friend of the show
another reason i got canceled actually
was william osmond
uh pokemane sent
a bunch of alfredo's i'm i couldn't
account for i look like i'm messing with
you did you said she's gotta go in five
minutes it went too fast but she said we
can chat another time she'll be sure to
swing in more okay
welcome to pokey super troopers unite we
love to have you in the ranks oh yeah oh
yeah exactly yeah brother zach isn't
here so i'll just verbally do the uh
hell yeah the jeff bezos
anyway thank you nice to uh have you
here
loki said peace and love i have a
meeting in five minutes please coming by
another time and hop on a call peace and
love simp nation simpsons all around
she's in love
don't let me catch you simping for her
ab
i'm sorry i'm talking to a married man
i'm married oh is it have to be a uh
he's a sexual thing
i think it inherently is okay because he
i was just saying because he's sipping
the what the acronym means
wait what is the afternoon
sucker
idolizing
mediocre pete oh oh i didn't know that
you did at some point and you probably
just forgot one more wait
you're idolizing my mediocre [ __ ]
because well he's my simp it doesn't
mean he wants to [ __ ] me i don't think
the definition is definitely no i'm i am
whatever you say i am i'm stim goblin
who else i didn't call you a clown
goblin
well i mean i have in the past but i
didn't bring it up
i love it i love seeing it on on
everything i post all right so i know my
hard work leads to that no simping for
pokey um no married uh i don't simply i
will not sin for pokey okay thank you
her real name's iman my sister's name is
iman fun fact
that is fun all right let's watch
williams
anyway
i'm just kidding
uh here's the video
so i thought this was great you know
william friend of the show
i got canceled because i
uh
asked him to
wait remember everyone got that was like
a whole big cancellation people people
were unhappy that he was not a full
guest on the uh
the podcast that it was only like a
short segment but that was like a big
part of like all the exposed videos that
i rudely
because it was awkward and
i had stuff whatever who cares the
awkwardness wasn't
from him though and then the ironic part
about that was that we uh hung out after
the show with him for i've hung out with
him a bunch of times yeah yeah there
there was there was no bad vibes there
they may have appeared that way on the
show but
so
uh
just a second he later came on with his
wife and did have a full episode he was
great at right friend of the show
so here he's quitting youtube and the
reasons are really quite interesting
this is great it's one of those videos
we're like oh is this titled clickbait
or is william about to eat
i am done
i'm done
um
what am i done with what am i done of
i i don't really know
uh but i am
i just kind of exhausted i make videos
to
entertain people like that's the bottom
line is it's like i want if you guys
don't know who he is he does like uh
tech
gadgets he's like an engineer and he
makes like uh
gadget vid comedy videos
yeah that was why he originally came on
on the episode that you got canceled for
was he made a robotic coughing [ __ ]
beanie and talking by the way nobody was
mad at the time or were they it was
people just got mad about it after like
goku made it maybe somebody did yeah i
don't know it really it felt like a
reach that to me but but we also have
the added perspective of knowing what
actually went on behind the scenes and
that it was very friendly nothing
happened he came and showed his beanie
we told him it was a short clip and then
well we had others
there was another segment planned yeah
and
we didn't think ahead to the fact that
there weren't enough mics for everybody
in the room so when he was done
we had to ask him to leave the room
which people perceived as rude well he
was like maybe it was
like well well it was just a
misunderstanding it was just awkward
because he didn't plan it ahead of time
we were new
uh to the podcast
but you said he's welcome to stay you
told him that yeah i remember thank you
thank you baby
sim nation i was there
baby you want to watch my mediocre i
analyzed that video for my video that's
why i watched it because it was
something that you yeah
thank you abe no you he was in the train
but anyway the whole point uh is that uh
the title of this video is i'm cancelled
so it's like a cancellation tour so here
we go
anyway
this is great it's one of those videos
what am i done with what am i done of i
i don't really know
uh but i am
i just kind of exhausted i make videos
to
entertain people like that's the bottom
line is it's like i want to entertain
people you know make them laugh
make them feel like motivated or
inspired
and then everything else kind of is
secondary if if it pays my bills if it
you know puts the roof over my head
that's that's sort of the secondary
effect it allows me to do it full-time
basically is is
i feel like i kind of live in this this
nightmare of making new videos and i
don't know when it happened but
for the longest time i would just make
something and put it out and i didn't
really care and as the channel grew for
some reason
i've been more and more terrified
this is really important
i've become more uncomfortable posting
stuff
and i know it's so first i'll just say
this is exactly what i felt when i was
doing h3 production video and why i
ultimately stopped is because it's
[ __ ] horrifically uncomfortable or
horrifically um
uncomfortable it's just
it's just unhealthy bro like we were
making a video every week and then the
pressure was super high and then fans
were always disappointed being like this
video was great this video was horrible
and then thinking like videos weren't
good enough so you miss a week you throw
[ __ ] out
and it's a [ __ ] nightmare and reading
comments about yourself
you know about speculating
it's just it's so [ __ ] bad
um it was driving me crazy i was
definitely the
most unhealthy mentally i've ever been
in my life i told ela once like every
time we got into a controversy or posted
bad view
it feels like
someone died like it feels so bad and
then you're feeling that every week i
was like i'm i'm
i'm killing myself i really i felt like
i was killing myself i totally
understand what he's talking about
that's why we pivoted to the podcast
which has been the greatest thing we've
ever done i'll see i know like it just
i feel
unhealthy the way that i
exist on youtube like it's not it's not
good it's not the creative aspect of
making videos it's the
judgmental and just i i don't know how
to say this like it's i feel like i live
in a constant state of like criticism
where i do something to entertain people
and then there's always
negativity that comes back yeah so it's
like you put something out negativity
comes back like positivity comes back
too but all i can think about is like
it's the fight-or-flight baby you focus
on all the negatives
but it's funny because when i watch
william osman i wouldn't think like oh
there's people hating on him i would
never even know about that or even think
about it but it's the same thing for me
right
um
god i know it all too well and that's
why so when we went to the podcast
my goal with that was to create a
sustainable
healthy format where we could make
content
where i wasn't in this perpetual state
of trying to pull ideas out of my brain
and forcing myself to make content when
i wasn't inspired
and it's made all the difference and the
other thing is kind of disengaging from
comments uh
you know
reading comments is like listening to
people eavesdropping on people talking
about you when when you're not there you
know they say stuff about they talk
about you like you're not there
you know you talk about people when
they're not in the room with you you may
love them they may be your best friend
your your family you love them you would
say things about them that you would
never say to their face
because you wouldn't want them to feel
bad or you would put things more
delicately to them
so when you read comments or reddit
threads and stuff about you it's the
same thing but you're constantly seeing
people talking about you unfiltered it's
horrible
it's well said good way to put it oh
thank you maybe i mean pereldo stuff you
weren't supposed to hear or read totally
so
when i kind of came to that realization
i was like i gotta disengage from
from this i've gotten better so i'm able
to read some comments like i read like
the top five comments on a podcast or
in a subreddit thread
i'll go read but if there's like
negative feedback you guys hand it to me
so i don't have to like get in the
trenches and get my brain scrambled
you know because i do want feedback
right i want
i want
constructive criticism if there's
something we need to improve
i'm all for it but i don't need
i don't need unconstructive criticism
you don't need to read like that's like
going to school and every single person
there
everybody in your class [ __ ] hates
you and just talks openly about all the
pro every single imperfection you have
and then be like well we say nice things
about you too
i'm telling you it's it's [ __ ] up
it's hard to deal with that [ __ ]
when when the house burned down people
figured out a way to be judgmental about
it and like that blew my mind it was the
worst thing he was getting time of our
lives yeah so william osman he lived
actually and where i grew up in ventura
there was a massive wildfire in this
house was a hundred percent
destroyed burned down
one of those things you see on the news
just a total wreck nothing
and people still somehow figured out how
to be negative about it especially
with the gofundme john's
cameraman john's brother set up a
gofundme
and and people donated money a lot a lot
a lot of money like more money than i
ever could have imagined and at the time
i had like 800 bucks in my checking
account like i had no idea what to do
with it like i
i didn't i honestly if you want to know
the short long story short i did nothing
with it for two years that money
literally sat in and like yeah this the
these parallels are insane
the same thing happened with me with the
first lawsuit philly d made of charity
fundraiser i didn't ask for money
philly d raised money
for me to [ __ ] fight this lawsuit and
it got turned into this huge negative
conspiracy about how i was scamming
people
it's crazy the same thing happened to
william how much money did they raise
what could poss what were people saying
about the money like what could they
possibly say about this it's more than a
hundred thousand dollars
128k is where this uh dude that's like
that's like almost exactly how much i
got
too that's wild
get me one of those beef euros with
french fries
thank you
unrelated
account because i didn't know what to do
with it i was so uncomfortable and four
like since that happened
people have constantly
like
um i don't know i don't know
i don't complain i don't want to feel
like i'm complaining no bro it's [ __ ]
up the same exact thing happened to me
complaining but we went to disneyland i
think a week after the house burned down
a guy named jeff who works at disneyland
in the park
this is not like corporate this is just
a guy a normal guy who works at disney
gave us his free his personal tickets
like he got us into the park and i
posted a picture big mistake bro you're
not allowed to enjoy life people donated
money to you that you didn't even ask
for
huge mistake william and people like
it's it's like it's not even that many
people
people were there were comments saying
wow i see you're spending your gofundme
well
like what i'm trying to explain is like
doing youtube has this whole dark side
of constant judgment and you can't
escape it
yeah he's at the firewall you make it or
you break
i almost broke
i almost broke
you need therapy
you need to disengage
because like he said it's not that many
people and it's not compared i didn't
i'm i follow william i wasn't aware of
any of this [ __ ] that's the point i had
the same problem
he's got to make it through this [ __ ]
it's the great firewall
you got to make it through buddy you got
to stop listening to those [ __ ]
were just bitter that you got somebody
raised money for you
they're just bitter angry people in the
world and you're subjected to a lot of
them they're gonna [ __ ] with you dude
just got to ignore them you gotta learn
it's like youtube will destroy you if
you don't learn how to deal with i mean
anyone in the public eye really
youtube's particularly malicious though
because
like everything you do there's comments
under it [ __ ] analyzing
my house
that we were renting
there's a whole series of people who
were debating oh he's renting he didn't
own it so it's not his house all my [ __ ]
burned down like i lost it all yeah but
you didn't even ask for the money and
even if you did you didn't force anyone
to donate you don't have to justify it
there's there are there is a conspiracy
video on youtube still you know what's
interesting to this day oh i i'm
interested in this but this happened
[ __ ]
years ago and you can tell how much it
still bothers him this is the same thing
that happened with fupa i dealt with it
for years before i addressed it
because you're like this is stupid i
don't want to complain it's so dumb and
you know what people are [ __ ]
psychotic
and hear about this successfully when
there's
somebody out there
i wasn't gonna name names but somebody
out there
making
dozens of videos about it tweeting about
it on a daily basis sending you dms
about it harassing you yeah keemstar um
who's retiring by the way i don't know
if you
heard i'll believe it when i see it
um
yeah we didn't watch it but the people
that were upset about the jordan
peterson thing uh brought it up right so
it's like yeah even after it's been
debunked it's still totally debunked
i went and debunked it in every [ __ ]
systematic way uh possible there's no
validity left but yeah people who hate
me still bring it up and the thing is
like if you go watch that video of those
those [ __ ] being like ethan climbs a
piece he made fun of jordan peterson uh
snowflake i'm triggered by this uh
not allowed to make fun of our
our cult leader
um
unanimous upvote no challenging of the
facts
ethan's a scammer but let's hear the
conspiracy theory i'm curious that calls
me a crisis actor oh that's and it's
serious it's not a joke and there's a
whole comment section a crisis actor of
a forest fire that burned down like half
the state
i don't think you need crisis actors for
that that's awesome but how bad my
acting is dude that's crazy
what i'm trying to say is like generally
90 of everything is so positive maybe
even 99 of everything is so positive but
there is there is this this percentage
of like this extreme negativity like in
the the x-ray video i didn't show this
comment because it pissed me off so much
for some reason it still
bothers me smart guy one of the top
percent doesn't even have a slim
girlfriend welcome to the modern west
dude you just gotta go you gotta get the
[ __ ] you gotta go to therapy bro
i really do think so you got to figure
out how to get over this [ __ ] it's just
some dip ship in so bro
[ __ ] people like
if you want to make fun of me make fun
of me but why
why are you coming after my family
because they're psycho like it's like
being up it's like a punching bag i feel
like a punching bag and my only option
is to not look at anything because if
even if i look at 99 of like positive
even
being online and making something and
showing like you give it to me like
here's this thing i made like i put my
soul i literally put a part of my soul
into everything i make like it takes me
way longer than you guys would imagine
to make a video and then and then
someone comes along and uses you as a
punching bag and even though 99 of
everything is amazing and positive it's
really hard to explain why even a
handful of just nasty comments can like
make you feel bad
yeah
i've thought about that a lot too it's
the i think the best explanation i've
heard for why we focus on the negative
and kind of let you let the all the
positive stuff kind of wash kind of just
float by you and then the negative stuff
you grab and hold on to it's fight or
flight it's a survival mechanism we
identify threats
in the wild where we're you know
biologically that's kind of
how we survive right survival mechanism
so when you see threats or you see
danger or something like that we are
programmed to
hold on to those because we need to be
aware
of the threats
to our safety and i think that's kind of
the only
really good explanation for why we do
that but you can learn not to do that
that's what i want him to know is that
you can
with practice and therapy and whatever
you can actually learn to
diminish that those horrible feelings
and like maybe i'm just like
weak
but it makes me sad and it's like i
don't want to not read the comments
but i feel like i shouldn't read the
comments because
there are comments
that say things like i miss william
before his house burned down
i can't tell it's [ __ ] insane
laugh because people are so crazy bro
yeah people i mean look dude i mean
it's like it's just the sad fact bro
people are insane i mean i get comments
like that too
and it's [ __ ] horrific man
you know
that's [ __ ] up though i would feel
like kind of defeated all the time
like i really just wish i wish i could
just make something
and just publish it and have no idea
what people think
that makes me sad
like what do you mean you miss me before
my house burn like why are you even
sharing that do you want to see what my
first video looked like on the william
osmond channel
if i never changed like that's what i'd
be making today exactly if i if i wasn't
allowed to change and do what i want i
wouldn't enjoy doing this
but yet someone has the like audacity
to tell me that they want me to keep
doing what they want me to do
but that would make me no i would kill
your channel i know i was like that i
miss ethan i miss the old ethan it's
like well
you say that but if i made old videos if
i made videos the same way i was doing
back then i you wouldn't even watch it
like i'm sure that person leaving that
comment wouldn't be interested yeah you
know it's just [ __ ] stupid
not happy to do it
why why
and so there's a place where the
comments sort of are even worse it's the
subreddit the william
what a surprise what a surprise
reddit moment
i've been through it with the subreddit
my friends i've been through it
had good times we've had bad times my
friends
and the bad times were bad and the good
times were okay
and i feel like we i think we've
garnered a pretty good relationship with
the subreddit now
it's okay
they're still still trying to cancel you
on like a
bi-weekly yeah i guess maybe it's only a
bi-weekly now though instead of daily i
mean that's a big improvement i guess
i'm used to it no
i guess maybe i learned to focus on the
good stuff more because there's so much
great content that comes out of our
subreddit it's true and i love sharing
it and being like look at what our
community made it's so cool that is very
true he's so cool
our subreddit is so cool
um but yeah just certainly they're
trying to cancel one if not me anyone
any of us one of us nitpicking
you know
they're canceling memes now
oh yeah we can't even enjoy memes
anymore
he's so cool
did we order food olivia you got me that
beef euro with french fries
[ __ ] god bless america it's
pronounced gyro
are you [ __ ] cancelled
yeah ready to throw your ass out in the
rain
[Laughter]
i'm scared to eat this mediterranean
food if we're going to a uh
certain location yeah i'm gonna have to
use the ghost toilet or something dude
oh you're afraid you're gonna have to
take a [ __ ] yeah i was just thinking
what's wrong with mediterranean food it
goes right through me dude what doesn't
you gotta say what doesn't yeah
mediterranean food is not known for
making you [ __ ] everybody in this office
has like just
the weakest bowels
it's crazy well that is true
okay well you're a vegetarian you don't
know what it's like yeah i don't know
what it's like
i'm just thinking we're all gonna be
ghost hunting with [ __ ] breath
that's what i'm afraid of
don't have garlic bread
well they've been dead well well
apparently according to what we read
ghosts
can cause bad odor so
should be interesting
all right william
it's specific to me like nobody stumbles
across that on accident like somebody
goes there specifically to talk about or
share memes about me and it's like i do
lurk there and i hate it i hate it i
hate it
90 positive
but there is there is just this like
kind of just i don't know how to
describe it other than kind of like
weird disgusting like speculation about
me
that's where i come back to your
eavesdropping on a conversation about
you
that you're not supposed to be listening
to
so that's the challenging part of
setting those boundaries for yourself
because
if you could if you had some super power
to listen to every conversation that
everybody has about you that you know
you [ __ ] up bro that's information not
for you man
um and that's what that's essentially
what's happening
who's somebody you guys have never met
and i you know
constructive criticism is is always
important right that's the other thing
because you can't be like i'm not when i
first was like having a meltdown and i
was like i'm not reading comments
anymore then that became a place for
people to [ __ ] on me and then i remember
getting tweets from people like on
verified accounts being on twitter being
like ethan's a [ __ ] he doesn't he
doesn't want criticism he thinks he's
above criticism he stopped reading
comments like i verified and i'm like
it's like you can't escape it and no
matter what you do even to protect
yourself people still [ __ ] on you it's
[ __ ]
vicious
i go i'm not reading comments from
mental health they're like oh wow you
aren't you're [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
don't want criticism it's like
you know point where it's no longer
constructed the state of williams videos
at the moment hi all first of all i
don't want to come across as
disrespectful in any way i have been an
avid fan of big willy since the early
days of his channel but nowadays i don't
think he has the same level of content
that he used to produce do you guys
think this is the case why or why not
yeah it's like why even write that bro
just go just like watch or don't and
that is i mean i don't know if he was
citing that as an example of
constructive criticism but no
yeah i mean there's nothing constructive
yeah we get to look like that on the
subway all the time right pretty much
i don't like ethan anymore we get that
[ __ ] all the time but i guess it just
doesn't maybe
does anyone not watch the show anymore
stuff like that does anyone just find
the show boring and like uninspired
and it's even worse when people say i'm
a big fan of bots oh yeah of course i've
been watching
i've been watching since the uh since
israel yeah since israel but like i just
can't stand ethan anymore it's amazing
how many millions of people watched you
since israel considering you had like
ten views yeah back then that's what
it's interesting
yeah
we say okay fine you don't like it
anymore you don't have to like it
you [ __ ] off nobody cares
i don't need
i don't need to know just [ __ ]
like when i stop enjoying things i
stopped generally just disengage with
them dude just go out of my way yeah let
them know
let's [ __ ] off dude just go watch
something else i'm sure
endless amounts of content we've changed
we've changed we've gone down different
paths in life you've i've gone this way
you've gone this way uh a [ __ ] i'm
sure there's something down there to
watch [ __ ] off shut up don't tell me is
it is it tough to not respond
to all those little comments no no no no
not anymore
back when i was small i would respond to
everything but now
again you have to remember people write
[ __ ] they don't expect me to respond
they don't even expect me to read it
and also you if you do respond you look
like so pathetic
yeah
it's just alone
like if you get in the trenches and
start responding to people it's like wow
dude and then that just becomes a whole
nother thing for criticism
true
i think it would bother me less if it
was down voted into
oblivion but it's not yeah
how much points
and even though i know
that it's stupid
and then i shouldn't listen to it or
shouldn't bother me
it still does yes sir
and it feels pathetic it feels pathetic
that it bothers me it was like oh i just
you know why like you're you're it's
like dehumanizing like people sort of
they put you know a youtuber up at this
like god to your level like oh this is
like this person is
you cannot they are unaffected by any
sort of insult or mean thing
and then they perceive what they don't
the problem is they don't expect that
you actually read it i think
but you do obviously yeah you need to
dehumanize them it's like well they're
not affected by me being a jackass and
so i'm gonna therefore be a jackass
nothing no specific no nothing
how am i supposed to learn from this of
what to do differently you guys don't
know a lot about me
i could be the zodiac killer
okay not possible you're too young
i could be i am the zodiac killer
i hide so much because the audience they
don't want to see me suffer like they
don't want to see me being homeless
but there's this part
i want to watch him suffer
on the flip side
where they don't want to see you succeed
people do not want to see
you be successful it's not about money
though but but it is it's like it it is
like jimmy i'm busy i'm gonna need you
to just hang out down on the floor for
like five minutes that cool buddy you
know me
as a youtuber i started off and i made
maybe 10 views a video i posted a video
to get 10 views um
and i made no money
and then i started posting videos and
they'd get 50 000 views and i still made
no money because i hadn't even monetized
the channel yet and i just kept doing
what i was doing
and like as more people watch
you make more money
but i'm afraid to do anything
i'm even like i'm even flustered right
now trying to figure out how to describe
this because i feel like oh like yeah
once you tell people that you have a
career and it's it's it's like you've
made
adult money then they're drool
do i even talk about the car
anything but i feel like
you see the fact the fact now that i'm
hesitant to to talk about the fact that
i bought a car is so sad yeah i went
through that too when you start making a
little money
and then you're afraid people are gonna
be like judgmental and be like oh you
change you know it's like bro yeah i'm
look i'm making money i got vid it's
like i've been through all the same [ __ ]
there's just like that weird
contradiction where
people
oftentimes get attached to youtubers
because they find them relatable and
it's like oh you know i feel like
you know you're a lot like me and
i really connect you or whatever but
then the more people that do that the
more successful you're going to become
and then you're not relatable anymore
and then they feel betrayed you know
what i mean and like i guess but if your
only way you relate to someone is if
they're like not rich then i don't
understand he's not it's like
i don't even know if he's rich
necessarily but like william look at him
i mean he's not out in the memescape
he's not he's the same guy he's just
sure got a little money yeah sometimes
he's got a rolls by rolls royce and say
[ __ ] him
yeah
yeah of course i don't know that stage
now that's what i'm saying i'm well past
all these stages
you ascended
yeah i was saying thank you
and i'm like thinking right now do i
edit this out of the video because like
in 2019 i bought a model yeah we gotta i
when we got a our first nice car we got
a model s and i was so scared
of what people would say if they found
out that i had a nice car that people
would start [ __ ] hating me
that's where you spent the fupa money on
yeah exactly should she suffer
uh yes
all
clearly
clap if you think she should suffer
yeah exactly it would feel like crazy
conspiracies even it happened well after
that and we leased it
but i got to get into this whole thing
about a [ __ ] car like what job do you
ever have to explain everything you
spend your money on to people
well three tesla
model three cd and get the s and you
guys have never it's not even that
expensive it's like a 30 000 car it's
like a mid-range car
right or am i out of touch model 30 40
000. oh okay
but that's not like that's like a
mid-range nice car right yeah it's i
mean it's not a
luxury sports car it's not like a bmw or
some [ __ ] or mercedes yeah those would
be likely to be more expensive yeah
[Laughter]
but i wouldn't i said i'm either gonna
buy used cars for the rest of my life or
a car that drives itself
and when i when i had made enough money
where i could buy a car that drove
itself i bought a kind of job itself you
bought a car bro big mistake you got at
least that [ __ ] yeah m3 is uh 70 grand
yeah but like model threes is like dime
a dozen here in l.a it's like nobody
else got to explain how they spend their
[ __ ] it's not a low end card like you
said it's like a mid-range yeah my whole
parking structure my complex all model
threes
yeah in la it's like the new prius
everybody driving it
and i haven't told you guys because i'm
still traumatized from the gofundme like
everything same thing happened to me bro
i was traumatized from that [ __ ]
gofundme that phil set up for me
so much problem
it's weird like people it caused so much
trouble
neither of us asked for the money
someone else did it and then it caused
like so much [ __ ] problem i would
just give it all back you know what i'm
saying well i needed it at the time i
didn't use it
i ever did like so many instances people
just say i see you i see you're using
the gofundme money while you're using
the gofundme that's crazy
yeah they hold it over you forever go
fund me money
i didn't buy a car with it though i
bought that with money i made exactly
there's this term this paradox i call it
the emma chamberlain paradox
where
relatability will bring success well
that's what you just mentioned dan and
success will kill your relatability
right exactly why
i'm not relatable anymore [ __ ] i gave
that [ __ ] up long
ago
that's exactly the sentiment you
described the emma chamberlain i didn't
know it was the emma chamberlain i
didn't know that that was a paradox she
suffered from yeah she's big time now
she's like modeling for louis vuitton
and [ __ ] there's just like a huge trope
with especially younger youtubers where
it's like when they move to la they
change
and i emma chamberlain talked about that
a lot in her videos
right because she was just like a
teenage girl i was talking about yeah
she's from like san francisco just
vlogging great school just going to
school and live a normal life and
and then she became super successful and
now it's the people that like still emma
chamberlain she just lives here she's
just successful yeah and doing the
things that she dreamed of i like emma
chamberlain she's cool i like her a lot
non-problematic queen
queen
and ian ready for the ten reddit posts
about problematic she is somebody can
expose emma she is an unproblematic
queen
i saw someone did an exposed thread on
alfredo by the way no more platforming
alfredo
oh
right i saw that too that he's uh not
really italian
yeah he's he's appropriating italian
culture yeah that's in the dock yeah let
me open that it's at the top on top of
the show that was funny i see that's why
i love the subreddit sometimes you love
their awesome bangers on the subreddit
oftentimes it's not all dangerous and
there's some doozies
some bangers too some flips and some
flops yeah yeah look look at this 3000
points please do not platform alfredo on
your podcast a thread
this was a response to everybody
canceling every person we ever mentioned
as a dog i was really offended when i
learned alfredo was not represented
was the dog representation on the
podcast despite all the controversies
he's been in first of all cultural
appropriation he claims to be italian
when he clearly isn't ask him to speak
italian he can't he can't even speak why
are you platforming such an uneducated
dog when we are out here being the good
ones i know this is a joke but i'm
getting defensive for alfredo i love
that dog so much
don't you dare then there's the poop
story really dog's eating poop nice
[ __ ]
stereotype it's incredibly harmful we
don't all eat poop and if we wanted to
we should be able to do it without being
poop shamed in front of thousands of
humans
it's awesome
and then this there's like we stand on
problematic shredder
so great
right now this is going to sound bad but
i kind of
hate making youtube videos me too i was
there it's not like i don't it's not the
video
talk to me slick willie talk to me i was
there i was you
and i feel like now i have the best
relationship i've ever had with youtube
i'm making videos four times a week
which i never thought would be possible
i come here i love it we've got a great
everything's you know what i'm saying
you can do it you're going to tell me to
end it yes i need to cut off william
osman early um which is what we got
for the first time but we've got to go
um it's a shame
we got to go
uh the spooky haunted mansion we're
running out of time we're running out of
time that's a shame i'm really enjoying
watching this video
yeah i think the way we know the [ __ ]
being olivia's like wait i thought it
was a secret well yeah but i'm
which is fair that actually does make
sense
since we do have to wrap it up
i really want to take a look at this
announcement video from the phase clan
before we go okay sure let's do it um
sorry william i want to fix i want to
finish your video because i'm just
relate so much but let's talk you know
you can get through this i was there bro
i got you know what i'm saying let's go
let's just this is the firewall man if
you get through this you can get through
anything it's just you know sky's the
limit bro
we all go through it
you come up stronger bigger faster
richer and less relatable than ever
[Laughter]
and look at me i live in a rolls royce i
live in a rolls royce
that car was expensive he had to give up
a lot to get that car so he is living in
his car now maybe that is relatable some
of our audience yeah who knows
you broke asses where's my donations
today
didn't see any super chat i didn't see
enough super chats today
all right i'm just kidding i'm just
weird and we appreciate and love all of
you that did that just kidding thank you
uh where is the can you highlight it in
the document yeah uh
right here
and right here is the truth is guys i'm
the same [ __ ] idiot i always was i
just i that's it i'm the [ __ ] i'm the
same goon i always was i just have a
nice car in the house that's the only
difference still rocking beanies and
actually the the real thing is like
having money has just enabled me to make
more content now i have people that help
me and support me so i can make more
content i have [ __ ] make four videos
a week now before i was lucky to make
one video a week because i had to do a
lot of other [ __ ] that keeps me away so
like you know i'm using the money to
money that i'm using
to uh [ __ ] make myself more
productive first for so we can all enjoy
more
i think when you wear shoes every day
that's what we'll know you changed
not that i don't like my got sandals
baby you don't like my um i love sandals
on a rainy day i will never change
wait what's kendrick lamar standing for
this [ __ ] dropped something new
childhood home oh [ __ ]
top five worse uh okay sounds like
nothing
he was at dodger stadium just dude i
want that new kendrick now
um here's the uh
so which one you want me to click the
this one
yeah
yeah their announcement video
so faze made this huge announcement that
they're going public i'm sorry who gives
a [ __ ] that you're going public like
they're obviously just trying to drum up
interest and buying the the shares but
like if i'm a fan of phase even who
[ __ ] cares that you're going public
good for you you're going to make money
like what do i care but when public when
companies go public do you know what
that means they get [ __ ] ruined they
get ruined nothing good comes from
companies going public other than they
make more money
everything goes to [ __ ] when companies
go public because they become
accountable to boards and shareholders
and everything becomes about profit
motive and is no soul or character left
this is a bad news for the faze
community if you ask me
um based down this is a phase that's a
phase out i know before we jump into
this um your wife eli is in the chat
she is she said hi ethan
hi ethan hi
hi uh you want to call her
she's home with theodore she she was
going to come with the the haunted ghost
hunt luigi's mansion but um
hi theodore if you're watching
hi alfredo sorry you got canceled
right here we go
eli you didn't see the part where you
were ordering lunch right
it's not that bad mediterranean food is
good yeah it's good for you don't want
to give the it's good for you
so anyway congratulations to faith
they're going public and um
well that's just really exciting
what's up guys it's faze rain here
what's up guys this is face tempered
what's up guys
and i
our biggest announcement ever
as you know we started in 2010 and all
we really cared about back then was
trick shots it's just
yo yo they put blanks eating [ __ ] on
their ipo announcement oh that's crazy
that's so weird why would they include
that i was wondering why faith blinks
wasn't in there because he's like one of
the owners but they just show them
eating [ __ ] you know we started in 2010
and all we really cared about back then
was trick shots it's just a group of
friends that's him getting arrested in
the club
oh wait i don't think it was arrested
but they showed them both known and
evolved so much over the last 11 years
into a global lifestyle and media
platform we really couldn't have done it
without you guys the fans you guys are
face planners and so that's why we're
excited to share this announcement
personally
did you see that in the background
what no i didn't see it it's been in
like every frame hold on i didn't see it
i just spotted something interesting in
the background you want me to go back
yeah yeah maybe just did you know we
started in 2010 and all we really cared
about back then these trick shots it's
just a group of friends with a youtube
channel
grown involved so much over the last 11
years into a global lifestyle and i
don't see anything right
i don't see it
on top of you it just looks like a
normal okay
ipo maybe it's maybe it's coming up
that's an announcement media platform we
really couldn't have done it without you
guys the fans you guys are faceplants
and so that's why we're excited to share
this announcement personally face clan's
gonna become a public company gonna be
on wall street guys and without you guys
obviously this would never be possible
this is a natural next step in the
growth of phase and the growth of what
face clan is team that came from making
trick shots is now going public how
crazy is that this isn't just a big
moment for us in phase 10 it's a huge
moment for everybody who grew up on the
internet with us we've grown up with you
guys this is really something we've all
why is he doing why is he talking from
the backseat of a tesla like bro okay if
you really cared you'd probably use this
really something we've all created
together i'm so proud of my entire team
here at phase for being a part of
something so incredible
that's it for now i hope everyone's as
excited about this as we are get ready
phase up phase off pays off
wow
congratulations i don't know who the
[ __ ] is investing in phase
i don't know why they're even going
public i mean like i just don't know
what service or goods they offer or what
the [ __ ] phase even is h3h3 humor how
like what is even the point of phase
going public i don't get it
well well obviously i know they want to
raise money but like why would anyone
invest in phase it's just odds well i
mean you know all jokes aside they are a
very successful esports organization
they're teams in a bunch of stuff and
esports is uh becoming a really huge
industry so you know i'm calling it
short phase
[ __ ] frog they're actually going to
be phased on like that's their uh ticker
oh that's pretty good
phase
short phase buddy
all right we got to go we're going to go
to uh luigi's mansion yep
so
expect that on thursday tomorrow for
members no no wednesday for members
right wednesday for members
thursday for everyone
thank you for watching it's all about it
it's been another great one here we go
been another great one death death death
crank about to get some beef euros
[Music]
[Music]
death
death death death death death death
death
to all of them